Facebook was so much worse than I had
any idea could be no one actually gets
to see how Facebook is functioning you
start a fight in a post you're gonna get
much much more distribution than someone
who does a calm response if your kid
uses social media for more than three
hours a day they're at double or triple
the risk of getting depression or
anxiety the average kid in the United
States uses these products for three and
a half hours a day Zuckerberg himself
refused to address these major problems
Marcus had to be the CEO since he was
19. he is also his own boss he lives in
an echo chamber we're not citizens on
our social platforms we are subjects of
a king
I appreciate you coming here to share
the book The Power of one is out
everywhere easy to find we'll link it up
in the show notes and all of that
um well let's walk through the history
of this a little bit for people that
aren't super familiar with your Arc
um and and begin with why you even
joined Facebook to begin with like what
what what was attractive about going to
work at Facebook because at the time it
wasn't that long ago it was 2019 right
there was already a lot of stuff things
about about Facebook at the time that
for this sort of uneducated person about
your life would make one think like well
why did she even go there
um so back in my late 20s early 30s so I
went into the hospital in 2014 so I was
29 years old and
um I my health had been declining for a
couple years so I went from being able
to ride 125 miles on a bike in a day to
being in a wheelchair in two and a half
years and so I hired an assistant who
was a friend of my younger brothers and
um
he became
like essential to my recovery and in
um Bernie Sanders lost the primary and
and my friend like he he he kind of like
fell into the dark corners of the
internet he began to have a lot of
conspiratorial thinking
and I remember how painful it was like
when when the Facebook recruiter reached
out to me in like late 2018 early 2019
and was like hey do you want to work at
Facebook I said the only thing I would
work on is misinformation
because like watching him
divorce himself from our shared reality
was uh just excruciating from How deep
did it go for him he ended up moving to
Indiana with some people who I I think
are questionable
um and I it's interesting like the thing
that saved him was he he met a nice girl
and he likes started going to church
again and like he's fine today but like
you know he he was definitely running
with some people who um uh have some
pretty extreme political beliefs so that
that experience with that close friend
was a motivating factor in you being
interested in in the possibility of
participating in the solution like
Facebook's not going away yeah if you're
inside that machine perhaps you can pull
some levers and I think it's like a ship
it's also one of these things where like
I talk about the book The idea and and
I'm not trying to brag here like the
idea that we have hundreds hundreds of
people in the world who understand
really how these algorithmic systems
work you know when the person said like
hey we do have a job for you you could
do Civic misinformation
it put me in like a really hard place
because on one side like I had felt like
this really intense loss and and it
scared me right like he was a smart
college educated funny insightful
empathetic person and he still like uh
spiraled off enough that like we would
have fights over like does George Soros
around the world economy right like like
stuff that any reasonable person would
be like no he does not you know there's
no space lasers like you know like you
know there's no lizard people
um and I'm envisioning the uh comments
on YouTube below this this video there's
gonna be a bunch of people who might
disagree with you yeah yeah good we
should have a conversation we should
have software that facilitates
conversations I'm not screaming at each
other but but um so I I I I felt that um
on one side you know if you know that
you're in a small group of people who
can do something and that that thing
could actually impact a lot of people's
lives and you don't want to do it how do
you navigate like feeling like you have
an obligation to at least do a tour of
Duty and so like I never thought that
like I was the only one I could save the
day but it was like you know there's a
relatively small number of people I'm
not going to go work in Washington we're
like I'm not going to move there but I'm
willing to do you know two years three
years and work on this problem and then
I can say I I at least uh did it did my
part and I ended up there and
um it was just
so much worse than I had any idea could
be
um because like like I said before I had
never really thought about intern the
international implications of Facebook
like I didn't even think I was going to
work on the international stuff I
thought I was going to work on the
United States
um and so it spiraled very quickly so
walk me through the progressive
disillusionment you know in specific
terms like what did you encounter
um so I showed up and
um you know it was like a couple
different levels of where I was like
something is profoundly wrong so like on
the the organizational level
um you know like I said like you
mentioned I have an MBA from Harvard
um I show up with a focus on
organizational structures like that's
your organizational Health yeah
um I want uh have you ever seen the TV
show Silicon Valley yeah so I can't I I
I failed to watch all of season one
because it's not a comedy it's a
documentary right right
like there's a lot of things they play
for last year I'm like oh I watched that
happen that is not nearly as funny as
you think it is
um but the
um uh but yeah so I I really hear about
how organizations function and
um and I show up and they tell me the
very first week so that they put me in
this boot camp for product managers and
for people who are not familiar with
technology or how like software's
written you know you have software
engineers and you have people who work
with the software Engineers whose job is
to kind of articulate what is the
problem we're trying to solve and kind
of segment that problem and the solution
to the problem into like the actual
discrete set of steps where like we're
going to solve this then we're going to
solve this and resolve this and together
we're going to ladder up to things we're
trying to accomplish and so I show up
and they say Hey you know you think you
know how to do your job but Facebook is
enough different than how other tech
companies work that we have learned if
we don't put you on this two-week boot
camp the chance that you're just gonna
like burn out and fail in the next six
months is too high so for the next two
weeks we're going to teach you how to
Facebook
and I get like maybe four days into this
boot camp and my manager is like hey we
don't have time for you to go to boot
camp you need to come and give us the
plan for what we're going to do with
Civic misinformation for the next six
months
so I've just come to the company that's
red flag red flag number one right um
I've just filmed a company I know
nothing about Facebook's problems my
teammates have never worked in the space
right so three of my my only three
Engineers are front-end Engineers so
that's like people who figure out how to
lay out the buttons and Plumb it all
together so the information goes the
right places my data scientist is new to
the company my engineering managers knew
the company we have no idea what's going
on but we are expected to come up with a
plan in the next like five days that
we're gonna present to like all the
leadership of the safety team so that's
the first red flag
second red flag is I hadn't really
thought so so one I had not thought
about the idea of Facebook being the
internet but I hadn't really thought
about the implications of
you know when the internet comes to a
new place how does that change the place
right like when we got the like in the
United States when we got the internet
and it started in the 80s right and you
started a few Ivy League schools a few
departments you know it progressively
flowed down a gradient of privilege you
know I went out to more and more
universities it went out beyond the
universities and the public you know on
and on and on
um but it took you know a solid 20 years
and and what's happening in a lot of
other countries is like people are
becoming literate to use Facebook
right that that one of the the first
experiences I had was We were supposed
to sit down and come up with how we were
going to measure success
and we had we had a hard problem because
we were specifically not working on
third-party fact tracking just like
people who do
um like say this is this is not true
like we were going to work anywhere in
the world where there were not fact
Checkers which is actually most of the
world
Facebook mostly goes in and does that
like after the fact Cleanup in like the
United States and Europe
um and so someone suggested well what if
we looked at expressions of Doubt so
like if you see something that looks off
and you make a comment saying uh I don't
think that's true or I think that's
misinformation you know we could count
up those and if the number went down we
were doing a good job
and one of our researchers uh said you
know that sounds really obvious like
that sounds like it would be a thing
that would work except for when we went
in and did interviews in India
people are coming online so fast
that when we talk to people with
master's degrees these are smart
educated people they say things like why
would someone put something fake on the
internet that sounds like a lot of work
and so just imagine I'm in this context
so smart people who are getting
onboarded onto the internet through the
lens of Facebook and and and basically
Facebook only without adequate uh
discernment tools to understand to be
internet literate I the way I like to
put it is like uh we don't realize that
[__] posters are actually like a
cultural treasure right like like our
our like 20 years of people saying
random [__] on the internet makes us
have a certain amount of Doubt of being
like oh you can't you can't just forward
things and people will laugh at you if
you use forward things in a lot of these
places
um you know people believe that the
information on Facebook is more
trustworthy because it came from a
friend right like if you're a front
scented then it should you should trust
it because you have that connection
um and so that's just like and there's
an understanding that we've gone through
that maturation process of of kind of
understanding [__] posting versus
reality on some base level even if not
great at least some right exactly and
when you think about the developing
World in that very different picture uh
in the context of of Facebook
proudly announcing how much money it's
spending on on third-party fact checking
Etc but not understanding or
appreciating that the gravaman of those
resources are being poured into the
developed world right and and for
various reasons are not doing much of
anything in the developing World
Language barriers resources Etc I think
another thing that is important for
context for people is like I hadn't
really thought about linguistic
diversity so like if you look at a
country like Ethiopia you know in the
abstract it's like all country far away
they have 100 million people 120 million
people uh they have 95 dialects six main
language families you know you have a
problem there where where when you have
when we focus on content moderation
instead of trying to make the systems a
little safer by default so that's things
like should you have to click on a link
before you re-share it like just that
knocks down misinformation by 10 or 15
or saying you know we don't have
infinite reshare chains we say it gets a
few hops away from you and now you have
to copy and paste you have to
intentionally share it further that's
like 30 less misinformation you know
those kinds of things are systematic
everywhere in the world gets the benefit
when we instead focus on censorship you
know content moderation
we have to rewrite those systems
Language by Language by language and
there's ways that we could do that
hypothetically in a scalable way like we
could decentralize out how we generate
the labels
but at least the way it's done today
places like Ethiopia just get left
behind
I can't imagine though even in the best
circumstances that deploying human
resources to to you know to handle this
job is is ever going to be successful
it's it's an impossible task to do it
that way and I think the problem that
comes up is is the context in which this
debate is framed which is one of free
speech versus safety and a big part of
what you talk about is the falseness of
that that binary so it's it's really
interesting like that that I think is
the thing that keeps us from moving
forward in the United States is that you
know enough Facebook Executives have
gone in front of Congress and said oh
everything you everything you're talking
about is so sad but you know it's this
fundamental divide between free speech
and safety or like Mark Zuckerberg has
gone on podcasts like this and said you
know I've I've really grown in the last
few years because I've realized when you
stand up for what you believe in you
know it can be really hard and and I'm a
defender of free speech you know the the
thing that's frustrating for me is is
you know this question of you you nailed
it earlier when we have when we
prioritize content from our family and
friends you spend a little bit less time
on Facebook you know your family and
friends are not quite as exciting as
whatever that magical post is the
algorithm found for you right or
um really tantalizing content keeps you
on a little bit longer but also has more
violence or misinformation
[Music]
having systems where we say Hey you have
to actually just be public about
everything like about what's happening
on your systems then you can begin
putting pressure on things having
protests having boycotts having
divestment campaigns and that provides
like counter-weighting balance Beyond
just profit and loss because right now
you know we talked about cutting the
researchings
you know saying hey you know if it gets
more than a couple hops away you have to
start over copy and paste it say
whatever you want but you have to do it
not just your instinct
um you know right now you know that's
not a huge hit to profit it's maybe
0.1.2 percent
but I right now there's no number value
placed on reducing misinformation by 30
you know we don't have to quantify that
as a societal cost right and it is it is
amazing how
much energy there is behind this free
speech argument given that these are
private entities yeah
there's the Town Square argument but
that feels very porous to me that it
just it just feels like we're trying to
document it all right now but it's
looking like they censored my book on
Facebook oh really
like they um my publisher usually can
um like Mark up like with a buy button
all the other books they sell yeah and
and mine violated the Commerce policy
how so uh because it's from me
yeah because as a DOT as a data
scientist you're going to want to know
like where who who's buying the book
where are they buying it and what
platforms are they using to purchase it
from and if you're not seeing any any
traffic coming from Facebook that's a
pretty clear indication this question I
have a lot of empathy for the idea of
the Town Square right they are the
primary place where people communicate
and in the United States like I I
actually really dislike it when
um like more societal Elites say like
does Facebook matter because like there
is a huge fraction on the American
populace that still uses Facebook as
their primary way of communicating with
each other
and so I I have empathy on the question
of like what should you be allowed to
take down or not but for for context
today we don't get to see what they take
down right there's no transparency on
how any of these censorship systems work
right we don't get to see what posts are
being left up or taken down hmm that's
so interesting so on the one hand we
have
evidence or a sense that you're being
throttled on Facebook in terms of the
word at least at least the buy button we
don't know beyond that yes no you can't
get that buy button up there uh and then
on the other hand and I have to believe
this is a direct response to your work
and the fact that the book has just come
out
um I think it was it was it yesterday or
maybe even today Facebook announced all
these parental controls oh really did
you see this no I haven't seen it meta
just announced they're adding new
safeguards and monitoring tools for
teens across its social platforms
parental controls on messenger
suggestions for teens to step away from
Facebook after 20 minutes and nudges
urging young Night Owl instagramers to
stop scrolling so this is good this is
positive change the timing is
interesting yeah um this is these ideas
are not new these are these are ideas
that you've spoken about and and
suggested it's just interesting that
they're happening at this moment the the
thing that
um interested me so much was after I
came out they doubled the amount they
spent on safety like they came out and
they said we've heard we heard the
criticism we're going to spend twice as
much on safety and then in the last six
months
um uh you know after Elon Musk showed
that you could lose 75 of your employees
and there were no consequences you know
Mark himself came out and said you know
Elon really set an example like we we
can have a year of efficiency
um and fire 20 000 people and and uh I
find it really funny that the thing that
is making them start thinking or at
least publicly making gestures towards
doing more safety is I I started being
noisier again yeah and and elon's cuts
uh involve the safety teams right the
safety teams got caught they did the
same thing on Facebook like I've had
um some of my favorite researchers are
no longer at the company mom and it
wasn't because it was their choice so
but so when they when they when they
talk about these large Investments that
they're making in in safety then how
does that match up against the layoffs
or what does that actually mean well if
you'll notice like a lot of those
changes are are relatively superficial
right they're they're I there's no way
that took more than 10 or 20 Engineers
to build right and and the second thing
is we don't actually know the efficacy
of any of those interventions like
imagine a world where Facebook said hey
we know that sleep deprivation is the
single largest Danger from our products
for kids right so sleep deprivation for
those who have not like dug into
literature uh it puts kids at Big risks
of academic deficits which stays with
them for the rest of their life it puts
them at higher risk for mental health
issues not just depression and anxiety
but also things like bipolar or
schizophrenia increases the rates of
substance use uppers because they're
tired downers because they're depressed
and rates of death from accidents it's
like not just Automotive accidents but
like all cause accident rates you know
Facebook would come out and say we
acknowledge what a large role we play in
kids lives we're going to start
publishing a very simple set of data
each week it's going to take us 15
minutes to do like once after that I'll
just update over time I want to say how
many kids are online at 10 11 midnight
one two three a.m we're gonna do it
every week
if they were doing that if they were
really serious about these problems you
know it doesn't violate anyone's privacy
but we'd be able to see did those
numbers move when they launched those
things and as long as they refuse to
release even basic data
like we should consider all of these
moves marketing otherwise we're just
taking them at their word well it's also
things like
um and uh Antigone Davis came and talked
to Facebook
um I think the week before I excuse me
talked to the Senate the week before I I
came out and she bragged about how
Facebook took seriously the issues
around body image they had a little
thing that would pop up if they thought
someone was at risk for an eating
disorder and like I intentionally you
know took pictures of the dashboard that
showed how often that triggered and so
globally it was triggering a couple
hundred times a day
right so it's one of these things where
if you're going to get up there and brag
about how serious you take this problem
and then do an intervention that touches
maybe one percent of kids affected like
like we shouldn't give you too much
credit um what do you make of elon's
Twitter
um
um there are certain things that I'm
super excited about so things like um he
published the algorithm right and and he
didn't just publish the algorithm he
published the history of the algorithm
and for anyone who writes code your code
in the past was always worse than the
code in the present right
um that one of the the sad parts though
is he's done things like cut off data
access so Twitter used to be
significantly more transparent than
Facebook he turned off the API uh where
he started charging cost prohibitive
amounts for the API sure so he and then
Reddit followed in suit with that and
there is an argument there like hey we
we're sitting on all this data you know
why should we make it open to you know
all of these AI tools to crawl it like
this is this is our value as a company
they should at least be charged for it
like that there is an economic argument
for that but I think the the they could
be making exceptions for for critical
public safety rules so there are um a
handful of academics that were actively
monitoring for things like influence
operations so so one of the ways in
which social media is now used in
Warfare is you have networks of accounts
that go and spread misinformation
and and I um I worry a lot more about uh
organized spreading misinformation than
say your uncle believing odd things
right there have always been people who
believed odd things they go to dinner
parties they say those odd things we
talk to them about it
um when you have organized efforts with
thousands of people spreading a lie it
it changes the balance of power and they
have a disproportionate uh impact
compared to an individual saying
something
it used to be academics could monitor
for those coordinated efforts
and it was the Twitter data was so
important that Opera influence
operations on Facebook would get
detected with the Twitter data that they
would see accounts with the same names
operating on Facebook or Twitter would
send the IP addresses over
and and Elon could be coming out and
saying hey if you are doing one of these
vital Public Safety jobs for free
basically you can apply and get the same
access you got before right right so so
as a result people like Renee daresta
Harris who have organizations dedicated
to kind of you know reviewing all of
this stuff and trying to make sense of
it I don't think Renee that's right so
now she's she doesn't have access to the
information that she had prior the um
I'm a fellow at Miguel this year and
um like they had a huge
um like voter just disenfranchisement
monitoring effort a bunch of other
public health related monitoring things
and uh they had to stop basically all
their research because it's like forty
thousand dollars a month now to get
access to that data Okay so
opened the algorithm close the API what
else has he done like and how are you
making sense of it I think his efforts
around subscription models is super
interesting so for context for people if
Facebook had had a subscription model
back in 2010 you know we probably would
have never diverged from that version of
Facebook you know the version of
Facebook in 2010 was about our family it
was about our friends it was much more
human scaled because there wasn't uh but
because there it's an advertising
supported business model they had an
economic incentive to guest of you more
and more and more content and I'm I'm
very interested in how his subscription
experiment will play out
because it it is having the side effect
of it is
um
the level of conversation is definitely
not as rich as it used to be
and the fact that he biases towards
subscribers has distorts that again
but the flip side is I like where the
incentives are aligned like but the
secondary thing is it also creates a
larger buried entry for accounts like
you don't have to pay you know eight
dollars a month for that account right
so on the one hand uh you know political
dissidents and and non-democratic
regions who need a level of anonymity
and access are gonna have a more
difficult time exactly you know getting
the word out in the way that they need
to uh on the other hand I like the
subscription model and it makes one
wonder what would have happened if at
the onset or the Inception of the
internet that that became the the
primary model as opposed to an
advertising model the internet would be
completely very different different and
we would have a better incentive
structure that would not have created a
lot of the problems that we're
contending with today and I don't know
how you unravel such a massive knot I
mean advertising is how this whole
operation functions but to the extent
that and it's hard to reverse engineer
it once that's out of the bag how do you
go to subscription you capture a small
percentage of the audience that's
interested in that but I guess with a
large time Horizon here maybe that can
tip in the right direction and to give
your listeners context like right now in
the United States uh the or the United
States and Canada the average user in
Facebook generates free for Facebook 55
dollars per quarter
so I always ask people like would you be
willing to spend you know 200 250 a year
on Facebook
and and it's interesting most people
claim they would not but Facebook has
run experiments where they they bribe
people not to use Facebook and people
actually value Facebook a lot more than
like 20 a month
um it's fascinating to see that kind of
cognitive dissonance
um and when you say Facebook are you
including Instagram WhatsApp yeah in
that yeah
um but what's interesting is that's 55
per user in the United States and Canada
it's only 14.50 in Europe it's 450 in
Asia and it's 250 in the rest of the
world and so it's one of these
interesting things around
um you know
I think it I think it would be super
interesting to see how things play out
as we see the demographic changes in the
United States because if more and more
young people leave Facebook you know as
those things change the place that
Facebook makes this money from is the
United States and so they'll be left
with these users that are locked in
because you know it is the internet in
their countries but Facebook doesn't
generate very much revenue from them
Netflix totally happy to pay for Netflix
I actually like that the algorithm is
you know paying attention to what I like
so it serves me up interesting things
that I might be interested in and
um and it's effective and it doesn't
feel predatory or pernicious because
it's not based on an ad model that's
trying to get me to I mean obviously
engagement is important to them they
want you on their platform as much as
possible so that's not great but they do
but they don't right so like they once
you've subscribed yeah but the more you
watch then maybe the more you share it
with other people and that that that
allows them to onboard more subscribers
I don't know they want um you to watch
enough Netflix that you want to
subscribe again next month but no more
than that because every minute more you
watch they have to pay for the computers
they have to pay for the bandwidth you
know and and you know think about it
like but there was that thing about like
well how do we get people to not sleep
like the whole thing about like how do
we maximize engagement yeah well the
night time is the big problem here like
how do we get into that you know
the the line uh the line is something
like um the the thing that he's
competing against is sleep right that's
what I mean yeah more concisely said
yeah
um so one more thing to just keep in
mind from the business model perspective
or like where do the incentives lie
um there's a big push from investors
away from subscription-based Models to
advertising models because the ceiling
of value of your company is much higher
with an Advertising based model because
over time you can get higher and higher
value advertisers you can get better
better at targeting the ads as you
accumulate more and more data and that
becomes a real value it's the future
value of your company because there's a
finite amount more like Netflix always
faces this like people don't want to pay
for the subscription to go up you know
they're like 14 was okay but sixteen
dollars you know
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores and beautiful and brilliant
people who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach
us something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so I've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with that
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
all right well let's go back to you as a
whistleblower walking up you know
walking towards this you know Rubicon
moment where you decide you're going to
share what's happening so you're
becoming progressively disillusioned was
there
a certain inflection point where you
decided I I just can't I I have to go
public with what I'm discovering here so
it's interesting I I um you like the
saying um bankruptcy happens slowly over
time and then very suddenly so I lived
with my parents during covid and
um one of the things that I'm super
super grateful about is because I lived
with them as I saw things unfolding that
um over that period of time you know I
could go sit at dinner and be like I saw
this thing today it feels really weird
you know like I I said this and they
like they gaslit me you know is it is it
me or is it is it them and and part of
what I was really
um I'm really grateful for in retrospect
is most most whistleblowers don't get
that level of support now they hold
Secrets alone and it eats away at them
and they go to work each day and they if
they try to raise their issues you know
people tell them things that make them
question their own reality and I was
able a period of time to like become
more more confident that what I was
seeing was real
and that meant that when we reached
December of 2020. so this is about a
month after the U.S 2020 election
when Facebook dissolved the team I was
on so they dissolved a team called Civic
Integrity it meant that
um I had already I'd already gone
through my period of agonizing
and I saw that it was time that that
that Facebook could not heal itself to
give you a little bit of context so one
of the classes I took at Harvard
Business School is called change
management which sounds like a like a
like a cliche business school class it's
like oh you want to be a consultant when
you grow up
um but change management as a field is
real a really interesting academic field
because think about how hard it is for
an individual to change a behavior like
a habit
once you put a group of people together
because they all have conflicting they
have a vested interest in the status quo
it becomes even harder to shift say a
company
and there's a Playbook of maybe four or
five things you have to do like they're
not optional if you want to change an
organization and one of them is you have
to appoint a Vanguard you have to say
this group of people is the future
they're going that way
um we have to join like you either join
them or you get other way because the
leadership's going to guard them and for
four years Facebook did that right so
they got in a huge amount of hot water
after the 2016 election because there
were things where
um it's not it's not like Russian
misinformation where they are asleep at
the wheel it's like
um there were these misinformation
entrepreneurs out of Macedonia that had
far bigger impact than the Russians
because they were just kind of running
wild monetizing on Facebook
um
you know Facebook spent four years
building out Civic Integrity to be that
Vanguard and right after the 2020
election they dissolved the team and
what is your sense of why they made that
choice I think part of it was that
um you know
they made good investment decisions over
a long period of time like it was the
only part of facebook.com that was
growing was a Civic Integrity team but
the problem was you know as the team
grew I think they just accumulated more
and more liabilities for the company
because they it went from having an
amorphous problem to having a concrete
problem
you know every time a researcher did a
project now there was a record that
Facebook knew these there were problems
here and they weren't willing like you
have to remember Facebook can't change
the circumstances of their external
constraints unilaterally right like
Facebook can't come out and say hey all
software um all social platforms need to
be transparent in the following ways so
that we can do the right thing or at
least they didn't think they could do
that
um I and so as they accumulated more and
more of this documentation it I think it
was just creating Conflict for the
company because they weren't willing to
actually go and address those problems
right so they're they're getting a sense
of just how broad and complex the
problem is and there's a lot of
documents piling up accounting for that
uh and without Solutions maybe better to
just go la la la la la I don't I don't
you know it's better to not see well
it's not a question there weren't
Solutions like over and over again
Solutions were being proposed but each
of those Solutions you know would hurt
profitability by 0.1 percent now if you
if you stack together
the 30 most important things 50 most
important things you know Facebook might
be five percent less profitable but they
also have like 35 profit margins so it's
this question of where does that
trade-off of cost come from right so if
you go from 35 to 33 is that really a
problem if we're actually addressing
yeah these social issues yeah if you
could if you could save the lives of 100
000 people in some country where
Facebook is the internet is that worth
point one percent of profit right point
two percent of profit and and part of
what you reveal uh in disclosing the
documentation that you that you that you
collected was that
um Zuckerberg himself refused to address
these major problems despite a lot of
well-documented please from employees
one of the the stories I tell them there
is is to kind of um Benchmark how Mark
views himself within the company or at
least how he portrays how he views
himself which is
um in the spring of 2019
uh the president of India began making a
lot of comments about Muslims that are
considered red flags for ethnic violence
you know he was comparing them to um
rodents other kinds of vermin which is
like a classic kind of step on the
dehumanization uh kind of ladder and uh
people started and so people started
having conversations about you know what
should if if he started calling for
violence against Muslims you know what
should Facebook's policy be around that
kind of violence incitement
um and a task force of you know 30
people with you know deep expertise in
these issues from all over the company
you know from every single uh part slice
of the company that would be affected
you know from Communications to the ads
team to the social cohesion team which
is like the genocide team you know all
over
um got together and did a task force for
months
to figure out what should Facebook's
approach be to this should it happen
and and Mark came in looked at the work
of this group of 30 people and said I
can write a better policy and wrote one
over the weekend
and when they announced it on Monday or
Tuesday
um
the policy was we will not touch the
speech from politicians
and the problem was he had never
consulted the advertising team or the
misinformation team
and so he didn't know that Facebook
didn't know who the politicians were in
the world um
right so it was it was a it was a a
wrong-headed decision and ill-informed
at the time and he didn't consult the
teams that actually knew what were going
on which speaks to a larger issue around
control and Authority within Facebook
great question Mark sits on what like 54
of the voting stuff so Facebook buys
back a huge amount of shares every
quarter
and uh it was like 53-ish when I came
out and I at least last time I would
check was up to 55. so like every every
you know quarter goes up a little bit
right and so it's and it's structured
such that there's all these different
um classes of stock right yeah um but
he's always sort of notching up his
voting rights shares so that he can
exert yeah basically you know Authority
control yeah unilateral control over the
company uh which is problematic right
um yeah the uh I'm the CEO [__] yeah
that was his business card yeah yeah
um so he's the chairman of the board
which means that he is also his own boss
because he's the CEO
um and Microsoft you know one of the
inflection moments when Microsoft
started being a little bit more of a
pro-social actor was when Bill Gates
stopped being allowed to be both the
chairman of the board and the CEO
and so these questions around you know
um uh one of the things I learned in
business school was this idea that that
we think of Corporations as these mon
like behemoths you know they they if
they're Eternal they've never changed uh
they have all this power but the reality
is like even what we conceptualize as a
corporation has changed over time and
there are checks and balances on those
corporations even if they don't
necessarily take into consideration
enough social costs
in the case of Facebook all those trucks
and balances are gone
right because he controls uh the
majority of voting shares it doesn't
matter that over and over again uh you
know 80 of all the non-management votes
say things like
um you know we need to look at the costs
of Facebook you know we need to do a
security audit you know we we should
have only one class of votes because
like you know you shouldn't be allowed
to demand to be CEO forever it doesn't
matter because he has that you know
um outsized influence of the company and
what is the composition of the board
does he have objective feedback is there
anyone who's in his ear who's pushing
back on what it is that he wants to do
not not really like it uh if you you
really aren't anywhere near Mark if
you're critical um so this is yet
another in a string of events and
incidents that tiptoe you towards the
edge of the club so when when I so when
they announced they were going to
dissolve Civic Integrity that was the
moment where I I was like oh they've
given up on the Playbook you know very
clearly someone had come in and guided
them and said hey if you want to change
the course of Facebook this is how you
do it
when they when they told us you know
your team is so valuable we're gonna
integrate into other parts of the
company
um
that was the moment for me where I was
like
Facebook can only save itself if it gets
help like it's not gonna do this alone
and so that was the moment where I knew
that I was gonna have to figure out how
to do something and the dissolution I
have to believe on some level because it
came in the aftermath of the election
it feels like well the Heat's kind of
off because we're now on the other side
of the election yeah there wasn't there
wasn't Blood on the pressure wasn't as
intense as it was leading up to the
election I think what's so interesting
about it is you know so the the fear at
Facebook was genuinely that there was
going to be violence in the United
States in the Ramsay election and I
think Facebook kind of felt like oh good
we dodged the bullet
like that the situation was resolved
there's there's no future Danger
but that meant that when the build up to
January 6th happened there was now no
longer like a single person whose
responsibility was to raise their hand
and say Hey you know maybe we should
turn back on the safety systems that
were on for the election so what's your
sense of Facebook's culpability in the
January 6 events so when you look at how
the movement that culminated in the
Riots of the Capitol
um you know it's it's very interesting
how those that those social movements
grew because it wasn't like um a broad
organic swell
it was a very very small number of
people
inviting hundreds or thousands of people
to these groups that they didn't know
right there were people who were very
actively understand what the weak points
were in Facebook
and then going out there and spam
friending hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people or making lots of
twin accounts they could do it over and
over again and I I think there's real
questions around you know
um even even in I'll give an example of
a safety feature that that might have
changed how some people made decisions
when you sit in interviews with the
people who got arrested at the Capitol
they say things like it I thought it was
real right when I looked on my Facebook
feed all I saw was that there was a coup
and that I I a patriot needed to come
save the country
part of why that was happening was if
you have a post and every time there's a
comment on it it goes to the top of the
feed very rapidly you can have a feed
that gets completely swarmed with the
this this kind of mass panic
and one of the things that was on on
January before the election in 2020 was
if you had a Facebook group that had too
many calls for violence they would do
things like say hey you need to appoint
your own moderators
which sounds like well what's that going
to do like aren't they just going to
prove all their own posts it turns out
getting people to care about a group
enough that they are willing to
volunteer to do tedious work like that
you automatically kind of rate limit
that group or they said things like if
there's too many calls for violence
we'll turn off commenting
right now that means those posts don't
go up to your top of your feed a hundred
times
um and so there's things where you know
the the the the the the heat could have
been turned down on Facebook for the you
know six weeks eight weeks before
January sixth so you you make this
decision that you're going to start
collecting documents and you you kind of
tap into this uh history this background
you have in in debate and how you
formulate arguments and that informs how
you start to collect information right
and so we all have this vision of you
know Edward Snowden and thumb drives and
how do you sneak the stuff out but you
were basically taking photographs of
documents on a laptop and then
organizing them on a on a gapped laptop
is that how it went down so the the I
think one way to think about it is like
when Snowden did what he did because he
was
um an engineer who worked on an
archiving system he had a lot more
awareness of what the security protocols
were and in my case I didn't know how
Vigilant they were being
and so like I had to be careful in terms
of saying you know what's the worst case
scenario like if they were really
surveilling me
you know what would what would look like
I was doing nothing
and taking pictures of your screen like
one of the things that's it is is
um interesting about it from like a um a
threat modeling perspective is there's
no way for a company to know you're
doing that
um other than maybe like the Cadence at
which you're you scroll
and so I was being
um as cautious as I could be because I I
knew that there would only be one chance
to do this that you know whatever I got
out would be the thing that was the the
record for history because they would
lock it down afterwards but you came out
with how many like 20
000 22 000 Pages 22 000 pages so that's
000 camera snaps yes yeah so that must
have taken quite a bit of time or are
you very efficient
um it's it's interesting a huge fraction
of everything that was captured was
captured in the last month I was at
Facebook
um so it seems like how is that possible
but it's one of these things where I did
a lot of like very very long days for a
number of weeks you make this decision
well you you get in touch with this
writer for the Wall Street Journal and
that kind of he had reached out to me
and that initiates kind of the momentum
behind this
um and ultimately you know you decide to
trust him and he becomes your sort of
co-collaborator and all of this and you
make the decision that the government
entity with whom you're going to share
all of this was the SEC which I think is
interesting like I think most people
would think why didn't you go to the doj
um so in the United States there's only
two organizations that have
whistleblower protections so one is the
SEC and one is the FTC
um uh the doj doesn't have by default
whistleblower protections and so usually
the way you do is you go to the SEC you
get whistleblower protections and then
they work with say the FBI or the doj
you also have the right to give
information to Congress that you believe
is essential for Congress to fulfill
like their constitutional role in
oversight and so that that was the
strategy for my lawyers and you're
somebody who despite doing all of this
you weren't looking to be in the
spotlight like you're a relationship
so many documents yeah and and so you
really didn't you want it to be
anonymous like the the whole kind of
public-facing aspect of this I wouldn't
say it's an afterthought but it wasn't
your first choice you had to be cajoled
into that yeah then I think the thing
that I had not
really thought about
like I was enough in the zone of you
know I talk about part of why I did what
I did was I felt like Facebook took my
future from me like once I knew the
magnitude of the problem you know I had
this fear that I would you know 20 years
in the future see a catastrophe in an
African country or in Southeast Asia or
five years from now and say like I
didn't do anything like I could have
done something and I didn't do something
and I I feared that I would lay in bed
and just feel guilty about it
um and so I had not really thought about
what was going to happen next after I
gave the information to the government
right like I I it wasn't really my like
my Horizon of Crisis if you will was
like not that far into the future and
after I left Facebook
um and like we got closer to the actual
publication date you know it became this
thing of uh having to confront the idea
that Facebook knew who did it right they
could look at the data they could figure
out and
um you know I think anyone if you go and
look at your life there's a version of
you that you could spend facts in
certain ways and make you look very
unsympathetic
um and my lawyers were were just very
clear they were like you know even not
coming forward you can actually endanger
people right so like in the case of the
Ukrainian whistleblower
which was also represented by my by my
whistleblower lawyer
um some of the people the media was
suggesting it might be weren't the
person
unless you're endangering other people
as a result of that and also it's easier
to cast out
um and aspersions on an anonymous you
know face it's more difficult if you're
out in front of it and the choice to go
on 60 Minutes and and you know reveal
your identity yeah I think was the right
choice
it had to be terrifying it was
terrifying yeah so in the background the
Wall Street Journal I'll give you a
context like yeah total number of times
in my life I've had hairspray I had had
hairspray like in my hair prior to going
on 60 Minutes
maybe two maybe you said you had like
Texas hair yeah and I like imagine
you're sitting there and you're someone
who like like my mother's a scientist so
like I I only would get to see her with
any makeup on like maybe once a year for
like a Christmas dinner kind of thing
and a priest um and she became a priest
uh in her 50s yeah um my my grandmother
became a lawyer in her 50s my mother
became a priest in her 50s and so I I
want to be I've joked about becoming um
a psychiatric nurse practitioner in my
50s there's a pivot up there at some
point for you I guess you know help
people deal with all the trauma that
we've accumulated from social media but
um like imagine you know like I've I've
never I've almost never worn makeup like
maybe I've worn makeup
10 15 times before my life I've had
hairspray in my hair maybe two times in
my life and I'm sitting in this makeup
chair and they are like doing stuff to
my hair and it's just like
uh
like I talk about this moment in the
book where where I was almost grateful
that there were so many people on the
set because it made me feel like I had
no option but to continue forward right
that I was like
um so overwhelmed in that moment I was
like well I guess I I ha I I don't want
to send all these people home if I don't
like if I chicken out like right now and
reflecting back upon that moment and
seeing those Wall Street Journal
articles and and watching the 60 Minutes
interview
part of me was like yeah like it's not
like like this was it's shocking that an
Insider came out and said it but what
you were actually revealing wasn't all
that surprising to me but it seemed like
it it was to a lot of people and the the
point that got the most attention was
the impact of Instagram on teenage girls
which was only one of kind of many
Revelations and perhaps maybe not even
in the top three of the most cataclysmic
things that you were sharing
I think this question of you know when I
say to you an algorithm could incite
violence right or or one of the key
Revelations was Facebook made a change
the algorithm in 2018 where I I they
went from just maximizing how long you
were on the site
to trying to maximize how much you would
react because your actions incentivized
other people to create content
but within six months of that you had
political parties on the right and the
left across Europe saying you know we're
being forced to run more extreme content
now like stuff we know our constituents
don't like because it's what gets
distributed by the algorithm right like
think about how abstract that kind of
Revelation is or like saying when you
apply a system like that to a country in
Africa where they don't have any um
Safety Systems written in their language
what happens
you know most people have trouble
emotionally connecting to something that
is that that foreign
um
but most people have at least one child
in their life who is you know either a
tween or a teenager and they they many
of them have seen kids suffer and so I
think part of why the revelations around
Teen Mental Health were so resonant is
people are really seeing the magnitude
of the harm today
and I I think you know you're saying
before like people had brought this up
before
um when you have Pro it was kind of like
a tobacco moment that prior to when the
tobacco whistleblower came out
you know scientists said known for a
couple decades like cigarettes cause
cancer
the thing they didn't know was that the
cigar the tobacco companies knew that
knew that had documentation to that
effect right yeah yeah that that's the
big differentiator there
um what was your
expectation going into that whole
experience and how did that match up to
what actually transpired in the
aftermath
um it went way better than I ever could
have imagined right like I I came into
it and
um they I think part of because they had
dealt with
you know whistleblowers like the
Ukrainian whistleblower you know that
that person had death threats even the
lawyers involved had death threats
um uh you know they had people showing
up at their homes and screaming at them
um we didn't know
how the internet how like the public
would respond to the information I
brought forward because there was like a
real chance that you know the conspiracy
theories that spread about me were
relatively innocuous you know it was
things like she's a crisis actor like
there's no way she could be that good
um uh which is a big part what of what I
would imagine was a motivation in front
loading your book with like actually
like here's all this stuff that I did
like I am good like I am smart uh well
like or or like I had a lot of people
help me right like yeah my debate coach
was good enough that he became 25 in the
country debater yeah math wizard you
were like you're like reading at like a
college level
my parents are both professors and I had
a college level vocabulary uh vocabulary
right yeah
you're very precocious
um you know intelligent child uh so you
know all of that kind of gets vetted out
in the book but yeah crisis actor yeah
but think about it like like that is way
less bad than like you know she's like
part of a network of pedophiles or
something right like it could have it
could have gone real weird and and did
you get death threats I never got death
threats like I don't I don't even get
harassed like like that's part of what
I've been totally Blindside advice is
because like most women who speak
publicly
um get get harassed pretty seriously and
um I have like one or two people who
message me occasionally on Instagram and
tell me like that dress was really cute
but compared to like what happens to
most women on the internet like that's
that's like a walk in the park what do
people not understand or appreciate
about the experience of of being a
whistleblower that is a great question
um so one of the things you know I
mentioned before my gratitude that I
lived with my parents
um people often ask me things like if I
could give one piece of advice to
whistleblowers like what would that be
and
um the thing I always say is you need to
find at least one person in your life
that you really really trust that you
can be fully honest with
because carrying a secret alone it
destroys people
and I realized
you know I got really lucky that my
whistleblowing experience was much less
traumatic than most people's
whistleblowing experience
and part of that was that I I didn't go
on the journey alone or I was in Puerto
Rico when I came out and so I meant you
know there was it was very difficult for
someone to like get in a van and drive
12 hours and scream at me right I'm sure
that was helpful but you had a lot of
help the Wall Street Journal you had
um this whistleblower law firm you know
you had a team of people who were
counseling you you had people preparing
you for 60 minutes you had people
preparing you to for you know here
before the Senate and you're a debater
like this is your thing so it's
interesting um I'm a product manager so
like product managers don't code like we
are not like we can code like I can code
like on on hobby things I could
um but you know when the product moves
forward it's not because I I did it
directly it's because I helped Marshall
help in that direction or like I helped
other people unleash their ability to
make impact and I think part of it was
that like most whistleblowers don't have
mbas like most whistleblowers are not
product managers and um you know I have
never needed to be the star right like I
don't believe that I uniquely am the one
who's gonna save things and so it makes
it a lot easier to say I I need help and
and it's interesting
um I had this experience uh speaking of
the debate
um I so if you were a professional
dancer
you take like a lot of dance classes
where you like show up and they teach
you some moves and like that's the dance
class for the day and the reason you do
that is that when you audition for a job
then come out and they're going to teach
you some moves they're going to see how
fast you learn them because that's going
to be a measure of like how easy is it
going to be to work with you
um when we did the prep for the Senate
um we spent two days so imagine there's
like 15 people in a room we're on like
Zoom
and you spend two days them throwing
questions at you and you try to answer
them and they say that's a horrible
answer like do it this way because it's
cleaner like that's like the content's
good but like it's not you know you're
you're not communicating cleanly enough
and I talked to one of the people who
was in that room
um I don't know a year later and he's
like you know Francis
when we left at the end of the second
day we were all convinced this was going
to be a disaster
um but you like Incorporated the
feedback that you got and so when you
actually sewed up at the Senate you know
it you'd done enough dance classes
through doing debate and having your
coaches yell at you and say like that's
a bad answer
that you knew how to like take the
future yeah but you've done enough reps
yeah growing up yeah that that you had a
comfort level yeah with that type of
dynamic
um when you were
before the Senate and also sitting with
Scott Pelley did did in either of those
cases was a a question thrown at you
that caught you off guard or were you
fully prepped and like how to answer for
everything that was asked you I'm sure
there was a bunch of stuff that I didn't
expect there were like I remember there
were moments at the Senate
uh there was a moment at the Senate
where one of the Senators
asked me about like quantitative
measures on Instagram like you know did
I believe we need to take quantitative
so this is like how many likes a post
has he's like do you believe we need to
take quantitative measures off of
Instagram and I was like well you know
it sounds obvious but that we actually
have documents in the disclosures saying
Facebook tried this as long as you leave
comments on there kids can still tell
who's more popular than whom like it
doesn't really do anything and um the
the senator clearly had not been given a
large enough bench of questions because
he just asked you didn't have a
follow-up yeah he just asked me a second
time so I would say that's probably the
moment that I was like most surprised
it's still a better question than you
know how does Facebook make money
the moments that will live in infamy
right where the internet is a series of
tubes yeah yeah right that's a good one
um the difference between uh
uh when Mark Zuckerberg you know
appeared before uh which committee was
it the Senate yeah yeah and then when
you appeared the sophistication of the
questions and the kind of knowledge base
uh was pretty evident like they're
they're playing catch-up obviously in
the regulatory landscape and the
legislative landscape is just miles
behind what's actually happening because
the pace at which Tech is iterating upon
itself it's impossible for bureaucratic
systems to keep pace and even understand
what's happening and I think that makes
it all the more important Impressions
um when someone like yourself comes
along who not only understands the
technology deeply but also has this
skill set in debate and communication
and you're able to translate these
things in a meaningful way that is
impactful can I challenge you on
something though you said like it's
impossible for him to keep up at the
same pace and and one of the things that
that like like I'm about profit right
now and one of the Notions were actively
challenging is the idea of you know if
we if we stopped accepting the idea that
they can't keep up with Pace how would
we fix that and I think the question is
like we definitely are seeing
acceleration in technology and if we
continue trying to execute regulatory
systems at the same way we did it before
it's not going to be fast enough right
technology is running way too fast but
you could say things like we've unlocked
organizational Technologies through
things like wikis other ways of bringing
large number of people together and
synthesizing their attention over the
last 20 years
what if we could just recruit
exponentially more people to pay
attention and synthesize that knowledge
so we could help the regulars stay at
base right and that's so your non-profit
beyond the screen
part of the premise there is
is onboarding as many people as possible
particularly young people with education
and like kind of running uh you know
walled off social media experiments so
that they're fluent in what's happening
um so it's a ground up sort of thing a
populist movement of sorts but how does
that translate into Regulatory and
legislative change because you are
pushing up against these gigantic
systems that move glacially if at all
well we have we have three main projects
right now and and two of them are really
aimed at uh I would call the ecosystem
of accountability so it's like
Regulators it's litigators it's
investors it's concerned citizens and
the second one is this question of how
do you have like Millions more people
feel fluent in how the the choices that
are being being made behind the scenes
of these systems that's like for Mass
democracy so we have one that's
targeting one might say the elites and
one saying Hey how do we do Mass scale
the culture change
in the case of the one that's targeting
more the expert class
um you know we're working on building
out a Wiki right now where we say hey
let's actually document the harms kind
of like how Jonathan height has done it
for kids mental health so so one of the
really Transformer things that happened
in the last you know five years was this
psychologist at NYU said hey you know we
keep throwing around the same like
one-liners about social media like
there's this famous line from a paper
that said
um social media has the same impact on
kids mental health is eating potatoes
it's like every time he would try to
bring up like you know hey something's
happening with the kids people be like
social media has the same impact as
eating potatoes and he was like I got I
have I have to like unpack this paper
and and the reality is it's very poorly
designed like it's there's just this
statistical analysis used is is
ridiculous but he said hey let's start
organizing collectively you know let's
come together and do a collaborative
literature review of everything we know
about kids Mental Health and then say
where are the weak spots in this
literature so imagine you took up an
approach like that that has been so
helpful in crystallizing and and
catalyzing the conversation on kids
mental health what if we expanded it
across the problem set for social media
because now you it's not just like a few
Regulators like sitting and trying to
understand things it's it's we can bring
thousands of people to the fold and say
hey let's synthesize together and then
uh one of the things that we think can
be potentially extremely helpful is
we're we're trying to
make the conversation about how to move
forward a little more productive by
separating the concept of we have levers
that might prevent or mitigate harm and
then we have many many strategies for
pulling each lever
and the example I usually use is on kids
issues so it doesn't matter what the
problems with kids a common lever across
those problems is let's keep under 13
year olds off these products like
allegedly that's what it's supposed to
be already let's actually do it
if you talk to the people who understand
kids social issues they usually are not
technologists and so they'll say things
like we should check IDs you know every
social media account should have a
password or a driver's license
associated with it and then my work in
China but it would not work here and we
could have a conversation on that but
just trust me
um and there's like all kinds of
implications for things like civil
liberties but if you instead said hey I
have a lever I need to keep kids under
13 off as you said to a technologist how
could I pull that lever they'd be like
here's 10 or 15 different ways you can
find it under 13 year old you know it's
everything from kids say I'm a fourth
grader at Jones Elementary two kids
report each other to punish each other
um like on the playground it's like you
pissed me off and I report your
Instagram account oh wow
um I know that opens up that's a Sticky
Wicket isn't that interesting but the
thing is once you get like a thousand or
ten thousand examples you can find all
the other kits you don't have to check
IDs and so our hope is right now uh
there is no regulator in the world that
can sit and look at a menu of what is
possible
we can't have Community discussion
saying what should the floor be like
we're not saying do it all like we're
saying there's some something down here
where we're saying this is what's being
done today this is what should be the
floor and this is what's possible right
and and so we need to think about
organizationally how do we move faster
and faster it reminds me of something uh
Senator Cory Booker said when he was on
the show which was that um change
doesn't come from Washington it comes to
Washington yeah which to your point is
all about establishing a Groundswell of
awareness and education that puts
pressure on legislators and Regulators I
talk on the book about the idea that we
like to think laws or a change comes
from
that like laws are so clean it's like oh
the law got signed change happened
but in reality like laws don't happen
until we come up with Norms we say hey
that's actually wrong like we believe
that's wrong and we come up with
standards for what it means to
transcrust that Norm and and that
process is is slower right and and I I
think there are ways that we can
catalyze that conversation and it should
be a conversation it should be a public
argument about what what do we want our
social media to do or what does social
media owe us
um because so much as possible yeah well
there's so many threads to pull on that
I mean I think that
um
on the one hand
there's a call to action or a need that
you identify in the book and have spoken
about many times to interject the
humanities and philosophy into the tech
space because when you think of these
Tech behemoths and your boots on the
ground and have been it you know
employed by many of these places
you're looking at very smart intelligent
math Wizards like yourself and data
scientists encoders Etc who are suddenly
making decisions at extraordinary scale
that are impacting Society but are not
fluent in certain you know kind of uh
ideas around like ethics for example
right and so young people making big
decisions doing the best that they can
well intentioned but perhaps you know
divisions and and teams Within These
entities not staffed with the
appropriate people to make those
decisions unquestionably let's say you
were a 19 year old and you knew you
wanted to work in a big Tech firm and
I'd say of people who get CS degrees a
pretty large fraction of them have
aspirations of something like that you
know you you already have a much larger
set of requirements usually than most
other Majors so you have less
flexibility off the bat to take things
that are outside of trust your CS
education but there's also the reality
that every class you take that is not a
CS class makes you less likely to be
able to pass the interviews to get in at
Google because someone else will have
double it down and so we have this very
um part of why I wrote the book is I
want people to understand when I talk
about the incentives are not aligned
with the common good it's not just at
the point of Facebook writing their
quarterly earnings statement it's like
every step along the way because we're
getting more and more Godlike Powers but
the people who have the skills to wield
them or choose what problems to solve
have very very little context on what
the implications of that technology
could be
um you said recently you told the Sunday
Times that tens of millions of people
will die if social media isn't
overhauled so what do you that's a I
mean that's obviously a headline
grabbing quote what do you mean by that
so when I joined Facebook
um and I want to fully admit I'm in the
same pool as lots and lots of other
technologists that went down this road
when I joined Facebook I had not really
thought about the implications of
Facebook being the internet for some of
the most vulnerable places in the world
right so Facebook you know surveyed the
scene in the late 2000 early 2000s early
teens and said hey we came to prominence
because we killed Myspace you know we we
came to prominence because we killed
Friendster you know these were social
networks for those of you your listeners
that are too young to remember the Glory
Days of the early 2000s you know these
were the social networks that people
were on in 2003. you know we came to
prominence because we surprised those
Legacy Networks
you know we don't know what corner of
the world the thing that will come from
will surprise us so we're going to go in
other countries and say if you use
Facebook we'll pay for your data
if you use anything else on the open web
you're going to pay for yourself so de
facto that means the translation to that
is that for Gigantic swas of the
developing World Facebook is the
internet it is the it is the primary
interface if not the only interface by
which people are interacting with each
other online which creates a tremendous
amount of power and with that power
comes responsibility and a big part of
your work has been kind of pulling the
covers on the lack of responsibility or
the gaps in in you know what should have
could have been done
unquestionably and and and one of the
things that I want to be clear is this
book isn't actually just about Facebook
it is about opaque systems that are in
similar positions because we're actually
seeing now Tick Tock and notice Tick
Tock came from the only corner of the
world where Facebook couldn't play right
like it came from China
um I I thought when I came out that we
had five years before there would be
violence caused by Tick Tock because it
you know video takes more bandwidth you
need a nicer phone and within a year
after I came out there was violence in
Kenya around the elections that was
fanned by Tech talk and if you look at
the drivers you know they're actually
related so I talked to someone at Tick
Tock and they said when the violence was
taking place there were no moderators at
Tick Tock that spoke Swahili
um and and that is the recurring theme
right so for Facebook they went into
these vulnerable places in the world
they prevented an organic internet from
Foreman so an Internet that was based in
companies that were local that spoke the
local language that understood local
culture that had a vested interest in
the success of those countries they came
in and displaced that made sure it
didn't get to grow up
but then they had these systems where uh
because the algorithms give more
distribution to more extreme content
you know if you start a fight in a post
you're you're gonna get much much more
distribution than someone who used a
calm response
um you know Facebook has set up a system
where unless you are actively kind of
turning the knobs or the same for tick
tock tick tock's even worse because they
push things towards being hyper viral
unless you have people in there going in
there and kind of blunting the sharpest
edges you can have systems that fan
ethnic violence and we've now seen that
for for Facebook twice Myanmar and and
ethio and Ethiopia and smaller
incidences in places like Sri Lanka when
when we talk about uh the tools that are
available currently uh for purposes of
staving off misinformation
disinformation for uh you know combating
uh you know violence
Etc that isn't cited online
um what are those tools we have content
moderators and we have the ability to
toggle the algorithm is that still the
case like what does that landscape look
like I'd say we actually have a third
one also which is you can make
intentional choices about how your
products are designed so like if we were
to roll back in time to 2010 right so in
2010 Facebook had a feed you know you
still it looked quite similar to what it
does today but that feed was not
algorithmic it was chronological and
because of that you couldn't have mega
groups like you couldn't have a group
that had five million people in it
because to have a group of five million
people that group might make 5 000
pieces of content a day you have to have
an algorithm that will cherry pick out
10 things to show you right
um you know we can make choices around
do we want social media this about our
friends and family do we want to have
social media that prioritizes choices we
make so I'll give you an example this
doesn't even touch the algorithm or it
does a little bit but it's more like a
product design choice you know Facebook
has done experiments where they say hey
let's divide all the content on Facebook
into two pools one is content you
consented to so this is your friend you
the friends and family you picked the
pages you followed the groups you
actually joined and one pool is content
you did not consent to so this is
someone invited you to a group
Facebook started putting content from
that group into your feed for 30 days
you wrote that's misinformation on a
post and a comment and they said oh you
like it and they made you a member of
that group or your friend commented on
something and now the post shows up in
your feed
if you just say hey we're going to give
priority the content that you you
selected that you consented to over
content you didn't consent to you get
less misinformation less violence unless
hate speech like your friends and family
aren't the problem right but you get
less engagement and you're either lower
you you get lower Revenue because you're
not able to serve up as many ads and so
the incentive structure is is upside
down and a big part of your work in the
book is talking about the importance of
of changing those incentives uh in in
Partnership or in lockstep with the the
urgency around transparency
so right now we have laws that say you
know if you're a private company you're
publicly traded you have to report your
profit and your loss you know how much
money did you spend your expenses to get
that profit
you don't have to report the
consequences of your products right uh
one of the major ways in which our
economy is changing and we have to talk
about this because only get more and
more dramatic is it used to be 50 years
ago 100 years ago
most of our economy was run by systems
where you could buy the product and you
could take it apart you know you could
test it for it doesn't have lead in it
or heavy metals you could put sensors
outside the factory and see what kind of
pollution is being imposed on society
we are moving now on to opaque systems
where the important choices the
important consequences happen behind a
curtain you know they they live on data
centers
Facebook has to report the profit and
loss but no one actually gets to see how
Facebook is functioning and I'll give
you kind of an example to give a sense
of of why the world has changed so much
like I talk about this some in the book
you know if I I know this is going to
feel like a reach you and I could sit
down and spend three weeks and I could
teach you enough coding that you could
ask meaningful questions about Google
you know like you could ask questions
about what does Google distribute what
what seems to be like
um uh what their preferences are that
kind of thing because we all see
basically the same version of Google
if you want to do that same level of
like accountability 101
we would have to recruit 20 000 people
and convince them to install software on
their computers or their phones to send
us what they saw
you know it's a much much harder problem
and so the kinds of laws that I think
really shift the playing field like you
know you're saying change comes not like
from Washington it comes to Washington
um you know for things like cars and I
talk about this in the book
by the time we met our watershed moment
in the mid 60s so like the fatality
rates on cars have been going down for
years in the 60s they started going up
again
you know there were a hundred thousand
Automotive Engineers who who could
confirm what unsafe at any speed was
saying or there was an insurance
industry that didn't want to pay out
claims and so they would spend money on
Research so that they could say no it
was actually the automotive company's
fault or there were lawyers who had been
looking for victims and could give you
representative data
you know if we wanted to enable an
ecosystem like that that could go and
begin challenging these opaque systems
we would need to pass laws that say hey
we need a baseline level of transparency
like you you can't hide information on
like how many kids are you know binge
watching YouTube I do it you can't hide
information on how many kids are getting
Overexposed to self-harm content because
even just a little bit of transparency
can be privacy protected data aggregate
data suddenly moms can organize so only
parents can make different decisions
about what products they let their kids
use you know advertisers can say I'm not
willing to spend uh invest in your
product but we can't do any of those
things without Baseline data in addition
to being called a crisis actor the other
the other criticisms that were levied at
you were there's a bunch of them but one
was you weren't high enough uh you
weren't you were never in the room
you're not in the c-suite you don't
really know what was happening at the
highest level and you know Mark right
after everything made was made public
kind of came out and said she's
mischaracterizing everything she doesn't
really understand what's happening I
take this personally it was sort of an
emotional appeal yeah so part of um I I
totally anticipated that that would be
said about me and so one of the things I
did was I didn't just get the documents
I got all the comments on all the
documents so you could see Facebook
employees talking about each of these
documents in real time
so you can see that people didn't
believe that these were crazy that they
thought these were true
and one of the things I really hope is
going to happen is um Harvard is right
now releasing the documents
um I hope like so like there's you know
if there's you know tons of researchers
that have access right now
um hopefully in the future like the
public will be able to access most of
them
you know the thing that
um is is sad for me about how things
rolled out like we had to do it this way
because we need to protect people's
privacy you know if you could see the
names on the comments you could see the
names on the documents like who wrote
what
I think the disclosures are 10 to 20
more scary
because right now when you read through
them you occasionally see things you're
like that can't be right like there's no
way that could be true and if you could
see the thread of like this person said
this and this and then this and they've
been at Facebook for 10 years you would
be like oh this is actually much more
scary than I thought it was what would
be an example of that I think just
things around things like the the
algorithms like the idea that there are
there are biases and what gets
distributed
um and that uh you know these things
don't have they don't have to operate
this way but they are operating this way
into a really extreme extent and to have
the comments in the documents also
um or stuff about things like um cartels
operating on the Platforms in Mexico or
the terrorism things or or how
Facebook's like censorship systems uh
take down counter-terrorism content like
there's just a bunch of stuff along
those lines and the comments validate
the legitimacy of the documents to have
those comments on there makes one
realize like oh this is this is a real
document and there were multiple people
engaged in discussing the ramifications
or I'll give you another example there
are documents criticizing that they have
brought multiple safety interventions
and that say the policy team has
intervened to protect the speech of
certain political actors right like that
there were there were things brought
forward that would have made things
safer would not have cherry-picked like
they weren't picking ideas that were
good or bad it was just changing how the
system was tuned and that you know the
policy team would intervene because it
would
um uh have implications for certain
actors what about the argument that you
cherry-picked documents great question
um one of the things that I did very
intentionally as I documented things was
I actually
um documented the order in which I
captured documents so you can you can
walk beside me as I wander through the
documents and you can see that it's not
like you know the random things here and
there it's like they're I was clearly
searching and just doing arcs
and pulling things as I found them and
so I just got whatever whatever I found
when I searched for you know teen
depression or that kind of thing but I
do agree that like I didn't get a
complete view I only got the the stuff
in the documents is just stuff that I
had access to
and some of that access was privileged
in that I worked on threat intelligence
um so I had access to a broader set of
things but you know for a lot of stuff
on on like say Teen Mental Health like
that was just was really available to
anyone in the company one of the things
that that comes across in the book and
when I listen to you speak is is that
you're not attempting to vilify Facebook
or Mark Zuckerberg like you're you're
it's quite the opposite actually like
you seem to have a lot of empathy and
compassion
for
not just that organization but for the
people that work there in the position
that they're in and I I think that's
interesting I think it would be easy to
just point fingers and and create
villains
um
so what is your your perspective on on
Mark oh
you know Mark is so interesting so so
think about it like you know what were
you like when you were 19 years old
I was in I was a knucklehead
I was a drunken out of control yeah
disaster I I was a disaster when I was
19. you know a lot of not a lot of 19
year olds are disasters like Marcus
Marcus had to be the CEO since he was
19. right like he's he has been
surrounded by people remember he's had
control of all the votes since he was
19. so everyone around him he has to
decide if they're around him because
he's in control and and you know I
became who I am today because I made
lots of mistakes and I got lots of
feedback and I had to live with
consequences of my actions
and Marcus had very little of that
feedback cycle
and I I really worry about you know what
what life has he ended up in
because I you know he's going on
podcasts and saying things like when I
wake up in the morning it feels and I
look at my phone like I look at my email
it feels like I'm getting punched in the
face
you know like how like is if that's not
a cry for help like I don't I'm not
really sure what it is and and it's one
of these things where
um
you know he's the last of the original
big Tech CEOs that's still in charge of
his own company
and I think part of that is that he
lives in an echo chamber you know he he
lives on a a an estate in Hawaii half
the year the other half the year he's at
Facebook like he can't go out anywhere
in the Bay Area without people grimacing
at him you know like it's it's not like
um if I had crossed Twitter
the Elon Musk Fanboys would have come
for me
but like there are no Mark Zuckerberg
Fanboys that feels like it's changing a
little bit with this cage match thing
yeah which makes me just just from my
perspective this Elon Mark like cage map
it's like are we really are living in
Idiocracy like I don't care about this
like what is happening
people want to see it it probably and if
it happens I'm sure I'll watch it but
like I I it's very strange my heart
breaks watching this whole thing play
out because Elon is trolling sure right
that Elon is being Elon Mark is is
yes he's training and the part that I I
like breaks my heart is like he's
leaning into this because he's like oh
I'm gonna show I'm serious like I'm
gonna show I'm a tough guy and it's like
he he's in a lose-lose situation like if
he wins it's gonna be like dweeb like
everyone like people liked Elon Moore
you beat up the more popular guy and if
he loses that's just gonna be like oh
you're you're a nerdy you know white
belt and Jiu Jitsu you know it's it I
he you have to remember
if we rolled back in time to 2016. so
this is right before the election right
in April of 2016
Mark was in Africa getting parades
thrown for him you know he was visiting
Africa and people were saying you are
the savior of Africa you brought
internet to Africa you changed the lives
of all these people and six months later
people are like you're destroying
democracy
like imagine Facebook is your identity
like everything you've done since you
were 19 years old is this company
it is almost impossible for a rational
human being to be like oh the thing that
I have spent my life doing actually is
hurting people and so it feels it feels
the psychic toll of that yeah and and
being in this gilded cage totally and
not you know having people in your life
who can check you yeah is is a really
interesting thing and the fact that he
is the last of these people where
everybody else has sort of realized time
for a new chapter or let's move on he's
holding on to it do you think that's
because
he needs to you know evolve it past this
narrative so that he feels good about it
again I think like the metaverse stuff
then you would think that that he would
invest in all of these things that
you're talking about to rectify them
well he he has invested um you know more
than we spent to go to the moon on the
metaverse right right like he clearly is
like oh the thing if I can pull off the
metaverse thing then that will be the
thing that I'm known for I won't be
known for you know early indications are
that that was unwise
um but you know on a longer timeline you
know that that may pay off I don't know
but those headlines got eclipsed by the
you know the Advent of AI which I want
to put a pin in for a minute because I
want to come back to that but
um yeah he he he shifted The Narrative
away but he's still this is his this is
his Hail Mary this is hail Mary yeah and
that's and part of what I my again my
heart goes out to him on is like you
know one of my favorite thing about
talking to journalists is journalists
gossip like no one else right like
that's the kind of professional gossips
in some ways and um back when the
metaverse stuff was really blooming I
had multiple journalists tell me you
know Mark is going out there and saying
people are going to spend all day in the
metaverse you know they're going to work
in the metaverse they're going to hang
out in the metaverse like this is going
to be like the next town square was
because he spent all day in the
metaverse and if you think about it like
if you're a person and you can't go out
in public without people grimacing at
you or without eating a restaurant
without being afraid of people coming up
and telling you they think you're a
genocidal like you know someone who's
gonna hurt Humanity
like the metaverse might be really
attractive because like you can go out
with whatever Avatar you want or at a
minimum if people recognize you they
can't Grimace at you at least until the
new headsets come out that's a very
compassionate uh perspective well hurt
people hurt people and he's just gonna
keep causing damage until we like help
him go on to Greatness he's going to go
do something else and he is so young and
he's so smart and he has so much
resources you know I I've joked before
that like if I ever write another book
which I I don't think is in the future
because I'm the PTSD of writing one is
too close
um you know I want to dedicate it to
mark that like I am convinced you can
accomplish greatness and I will not give
up till you do you know that's that's
sweet yeah has he reached out to you
he's never had any communication with
him even even by proxy through somebody
else nope
nope they pretend I don't exist
interesting but they won't comment on
the book they won't well that's a talk
about a no-win situation for them
um but you have said that under certain
circumstances you would go back and work
at Facebook yeah we we can't give up on
Facebook right like I think the most
important the most important work I
could do is if they actually wanted to
fix it is like work on like how do we
how do we make sure it can function
safely
you know in the places where it is the
internet because I think there are
strategies where even if you even if you
didn't want to necessarily do it the way
I would suggest doing it which is like
let's go in there and add the friction
like add the intentionality around
sharing that kind of thing
um you know even if you did want to keep
a Content moderation strategy you know
beginning to work on decentralized
content moderation like imagine if and
like um there's a scholar named Ethan
Zuckerman at UMass and Amherst who talks
about the idea that right now we are
subjects of a king on our social
platforms you know we can follow the
laws we cannot follow the laws we can go
to another place but we're not citizens
you know in a democracy you know it's
not just that we have rights we have
responsibilities you know we do jury
duty we have other obligations to our
communities you know you know there's a
way that we could be scaling up even the
current ways of doing safety into these
places but we'd have to say you have to
do some of the labor too the evolution
Beyond decentralizing content moderation
would be decentralizing the entire
social network I mean this is Jack
dorsey's whole thing right like in his
dreams Twitter would be a decentralized
system
um is that something that you see
emerging in the near future I think
there's a real player I think there's
really interesting opportunities around
things like Creator owned social
networks so like you know we talked
about before the idea of these are
advertising supported platforms if
people don't create they don't get
there's no ads to you can't run ads
against him
um I think a world where people who
participate have the ability to
influence how the system is governed is
a thing that I think will very likely
happen at some point in the future
because people value these spaces so
much
and if people knew there could be a
world where they would have a say in
these spaces I think that would be
compelling for them well we're in a bit
of a chaos adolescence phase right now
with the emergence of all of these
smaller kind of Twitter analogs and the
emergence of the sub-stackification of
of Journalism and I feel like we're
we're sort of fight trying to find our
feet in all of this but it's a little
strange right now to not really know
like do I subscribe to this or this or
how many subscriptions am I actually
gonna get am I actually gonna be up for
and how is this all gonna play out is
there going to be a consolidation or is
there going to be a clear winner that's
going to emerge from all of these you
know nascent little networks that are
popping up right one of the ones that
I'm really excited by is called post
news and like if I if let's say we pass
transparency laws tomorrow like the one
I would want to work on is post News why
is that um so one of the things I worked
on at Facebook that I talk about is we
did influence modeling you know we said
hey like we can actually model human
relationships and like how does
influence percolate between people
that's actually really important for
detecting like a fake person versus a
real person right
um because it's very hard to fake the
constellation of relationships that real
humans exist within
um uh post news is is founded by the guy
who did ways and
um part of why Waze was successful in
literally having just the crowd map the
world was it thought about the idea of
credibility and the idea that
credibility can percolate you know can
it can propagate out amongst the graph
and so they're taking into consideration
this question of of how do people have
influence and and how can we have
credibility that grows and evolves over
time so you're not having a centralized
authority to say you have credibility
it's saying hey can we watch how this
person
interacts with the ecosystem and how
other people validate them can we build
systems that are are you know truth from
the ground up instead of truth from on
high and not based on an ad model uh I
think I think they're not based on an ad
model I think they're subscription-based
so so beyond that if you were designing
the ultimate social network for the
future what else would be built into
that um
so that that so I think it's always
important to there's people talk about
social media as a thing like it's really
kind of two two main worlds it's it's
broadcast social media it's like Twitter
uh you speak on Twitter not because you
care about
um or like Tick Tock for example
creators crayon Tech talk not because
they're trying to reach grandma is
because they're trying to reach as many
people as possible and so they'll repost
their videos onto YouTube or onto
Instagram and people watch tick tock not
to follow any particular person but to
see what's possible entertained yeah be
entertained but on places like Facebook
it's it's personal social media like you
you post your baby photo not because you
want a random person to see it you want
Grandma to see it and so we we I think
we always have to be a little bit
careful when we say like what would the
ideal social media be because it's a
question of Ideal for what
and and I think in the case of personal
social media I really like human scaled
personal media it's like my or social
media like my my primary social media
right now I was about to hold up my
phone but my phone is gone over here
um I I
my is signal it's like a group chat you
know I have maybe 50 group chats they
have different themes like I have uh one
called Doom news and it's like about war
and destruction you know global warming
and all those things and people spread
news on those themes
um versus like ones that are like your
local pub they're like one of my friends
hosts for you know 40 of us or something
and and this is this question of like
what do we want to get from social media
we want connection we want to have a
lens on the world we want to stay in
touch with people and and we don't need
to have half a million person groups to
do that
and so I think for me good social media
is at the scale that that the
institutions that humans have evolved
over time can function at so like we
have the concept of a dinner party we
have the concept of a cocktail party we
have the concept of a church Parish of a
university like these are concepts of
communication like a a convention right
we have scale it goes up to maybe 25 000
people
beyond that
um it gets a lot more complicated like
you do have to have these much longer
conversations about governance yeah and
I think most of the things that we want
to get on social media can be
accomplished in communities that have
less than 25 000 people yeah it's
interesting though I when I hear you
saying that yeah um the missing piece
for me as somebody who creates on the
internet and has built a career
you know premised upon this free
distribution you know model and access
to lots of people and this whole
influencer economy that's kind of
emerged from it is the democratization
of of the voice which has its positives
and and negatives but I think I think
you could still host content so
something like YouTube you host the
content and this question of like where
people discuss the content you know do
you have half a million person groups
and and how what kinds of information
end up propagating in a world where you
have a megaphone that goes to a million
people versus a megaphone that goes to
25 000 people right depth versus bro
because because like when you have a 25
000 person community like you can have
like a Discord server and you don't need
an algorithm like humans mediate what
information you receive once you get
above that you know you end up in a when
you have a single Channel you know like
a Facebook group that has one stream and
has half a million people the only way
you can actually navigate that content
is with an algorithm yeah and now you
have to have conversations around what
are my rights to resetting that
algorithm what are my rights to seeing
that algorithm you know that kind of
thing as a data scientist a lot of
people you hear a lot of people saying
well we don't even know how these
algorithms work
yeah true oh yeah what parts of it do
you understand and which parts of it
elude even someone like yourself so it's
one of these things where you know this
is a very young field like this is one
of these things where I talk about in
the book and and we can design a system
and say this is the data we put into it
like we can we can describe that we can
see it we can you know when Elon
published the algorithm like he can see
what Provisions it says but the problem
is that all these things work together
in ways that are unexpected like no one
at Facebook when they made the shift
from saying can we keep you on the
platform as long as possible to can we
get you to react as much as possible no
one said I think this is going to lead
to more extreme content like no one no
one set out to do that and and I I want
to validate the things that Facebook has
said you know they say we don't
recognize these allegations we would
never intend to do that I don't think
they did
but the problem is that when they
learned there were these side effects
and and and right now the only people
who get to ask questions about could
there be side effects are the people
inside the companies
um you know people who have a vested
interest in not knowing
you know when they learned that there
were these consequences
um and to be clear like the the shift
was big enough that like the CEO of
BuzzFeed wrote to Facebook and said I
think something's broken
Jonah Peretti um I don't know I don't
remember which which gender it was would
have been in like 2018 or 2019 so I
don't know which which era that is yeah
that's that's it's it's wild yeah and
it's getting Wilder right like when we
think about
um what went down in terms of election
interference in 2016 and in 2020 yeah it
feels kind of very you know kind of not
that big of a deal in consideration with
what we're contending as we you know
Korean yeah towards the 2024 election
um everything is now suddenly infinitely
more complicated due to the release of
these various llms yeah the rapid growth
of generative AI deep fake technology
like the tools that are now available on
the disinformation battlefield are just
extraordinarily powerful so how do you
think about how those tools are going to
be deployed and what we can expect as we
you know move towards November so I
think there's there's two areas that we
need to really
pay attention to so so one is
um you know when Mark Zuckerberg excuse
me when Elon Musk fired a lot of his
safety teams it really shifted the
information environment so one of my
um uh my husband and I like to watch
YouTube together because we're nerdy and
there's a guy named Peter zyhand who
follows a lot of the politics in Russia
you know he was talking about how it
used to be his one of his best status
sources was Twitter
and when Elon came in he ended up
blocking a lot of people who were in in
Russia but he also
um like because he fired the teams that
were looking for the coordinated
Behavior you can really obviously tell
the trolls on both sides of the conflict
now just outweigh the real voices and so
one is we are investing Less in Catching
Bad actors but the second is the way the
tools have changed what's even possible
with misinformation so for for context
for people one of the ways we used to
catch those Bots or like catch the
networks of people who were pushing an
information operation was we look for a
repetition
so you know there's always this
interesting trade-off between
how much distribution can you do and how
much unique content can you do right so
if you you really don't want to get
caught you write a different thing every
time before the large language models
came out you you were limited you know
you weren't going to reach a ton of
people if every single thing you posted
was unique so you could start looking
and saying interesting you keep sharing
the same links or or this group of
people keep saying very very similar
things or maybe even the same thing
right and it becomes clear that this is
a thought Farm yeah right um or like
China was particularly egregious at this
because they would do things like they
would have brigades of tens of thousands
of people who would just like flood the
common threads on dissidence posts with
like just the Chinese flag you know like
like if you can tell this is all the
same thing
um when you start having large language
models it's now possible to go and
generate tens of thousands of unique
pieces of content that all basically say
the same thing but say it in slightly
different ways
um and that makes it a lot harder to see
that coordination or for example you
know
um part of what makes misinformation so
pernicious is consensus reality is like
a channel you know there's there's not
like a huge Continuum of what you can
talk about there's like you know we can
sit and come to a view of like reality
if we talk long enough
um when it comes to misinformation it
can play in the entire field of ideas
and whatever is like the most seductive
or like uh most incendiary on the
algorithm that's the thing that gets
distributed
in a world with large language models
you can generate 10 000 different
variations and send them to lots of
different nooks and figure out what meme
like what idea is most seductive and
that that just supercharges what can be
done with a misinformation campaign
it's terrifying it is and that that
doesn't even get into all the Deep fake
stuff when you can mock somebody's voice
or their likeness in a compelling way
that's indistinguishable from reality
then our footing in what is real and
what isn't real vanishes yeah and things
get really scary very quickly so this is
you know when I talked about the idea of
the post news is like a really
interesting approach in my mind
um you know we we part of why I think we
need to step away from content
moderation as the solution
or like censorship as the solution is it
presumes that we can go in there and
establish true and false right
a different approach is to come in and
say hey
um you know
information operations promoting lies is
much more dangerous than most things
um it is very hard if you are in
information operation operative
to have a robust real set of
relationships with people like one of
the things I talk about in the book is
this idea of how would you catch a fake
person or like how do you catch someone
who is behaving in an authentic way and
so if you are really acutely modeling
and saying hey you you have friends you
have a family you have people you
regularly interact with who interact
with you back
we can tell you are an organic human
if you have a fake human you know it's
like a an llm they can try to guess what
do real people look like but they're not
going to be perfect
and if they if your whole network uses
the same assumptions now your network
will stand out as being a clump of
people who act in a slightly anomalous
way yeah I like that I mean the the idea
being traditionally if you wanted to see
whether someone's a real person go to
their Twitter account oh they just
created the account last week they don't
you know they they don't follow anybody
that I know or none of their followers
or anybody that I know they this all
seems manufactured you can kind of get
to the bottom of it pretty quickly what
you're saying is create a matrix of
credibility yeah that establishes this
person is real with a history of you
know deep relationships and interactions
with other credible people that
um over time establishes somebody as a
worthy distributor of information yeah
this person looks like they're a real
person they're having real conversations
and even if I disagree with them the
idea that they are a real person means
they are less dangerous than they are
part of an operation sometimes it's like
yeah we're having a conversation about
just trying to figure out who's a real
person or not like it's insane right
yeah
um it's we are living and this is part
of why we have to start having more
transparency because we have tools where
we can start saying hey we got we got to
move this ball down the field
um but there is no economic incentive
today to do those things on their own so
what are we going to do Francis like
what's the solution here how do we how
do we put a better foot forward so part
of I think the first step is is is just
and this is a big part about why I wrote
the book like I'm I think of the things
that I regret the most about the rule
out of my book is is no conservative
media has has offered to like talk to me
right like I haven't been on Fox News I
haven't uh we've reached out to a number
of of course I would think they'd be
happy to talk to you I would think so
too because like I've been saying
consistently since the beginning you
know content moderation is a flat
strategy but Facebook spent a huge sum
of money on a whisper campaign saying
you know she's a dark horse for
censorship
um
and so I think the place we start from
is an idea that people have the right to
see how these systems work right like I
should have the right to know I am not
allowed to sell my book on Facebook
right we the public should be able to
see what content gets taken down right
now the only avenues that we have are
you can appeal to the Facebook oversight
board but it disappears into a black
hole right
um
things can really change if we have
transparency and and and so we need to
First work on how do we make that a
bipartisan issue that we cannot have an
information environment that is run by a
private company in the dark and have a
democracy and the second thing is like
so how might we actually do that so um
face uh Europe passed a law called the
Digital Services act last year
um I talk about in the book
um that basically it sounds it sounds
pretty blah it's like you know if you
know there's a risk to your platform you
got to tell us about it like we know you
get to operate behind the curtain but we
can't see we'll never catch up with you
unless you tell us what you already know
you have to tell us what your plan is
for reducing that risk and you need to
give us enough data that we can see that
you're making progress and if we ask you
a question you have to give us an answer
and if we don't comply so it's I think
it's like 10 of global revenues oh wow
a real one though when you have a 35
profit margin it's possible Facebook
would come out and say we are now 25.
it's just a business expense business
expense right what is your your sense of
the reliability of something like that
passing in the United States you know
it's interesting if you'd ask to me two
months ago I would have given you a much
more negative answer but the Surgeon
General came out and with their advisory
you know about a month ago
and just for context for listeners
there's been like under 15 Surgeon
General advisories since the 60s you
know they're things like cigarettes
cause cancer seat belts save lives
breastfeeding is good for babies like
stuff that we kind of take as duh
statements today but they there was
ambiguity before those advisories came
out and but historically when an
advisory has come out within two to
three years after an advisory something
happens on average and so
um I think there's a good chance that
something's going to happen around kids
and my hope is that we can scaffold
towards a broader transparency law from
there what do you mean something's gonna
happen around kids meaning there will be
yeah like a a sort of political will to
do something because of our shared
concern of how these things are
impacting mental health yeah um for for
context like there there have been laws
that have been starting to pass so like
Montana banned Tick Tock which I don't
support
um or like Utah came out and and passed
a fairly extensive law about parental
oversight of these systems
um you know these are conservative
States and and uh the way I usually
frame this for people is
every societal issue has some finite
number of kids that we're willing to
harm
so in the case of cars we put
eight-year-olds in car seats like
eight-year-olds in car seats saves like
tens of kids it's like 60 kids a year
versus like having a six-year-old in a
car seat think of how many fights with
eight-year-olds about car seats take
place every day because we put eight
year olds in car seats or like how much
money is spent on eight-year-old car
seats but we we as a society say those
60 lives are worth a huge amount to us
when it comes to things like guns we're
willing to accept many many more kids
being harmed because of the societal
value that we place on on guard on guns
I think we are reaching a Tipping Point
when it comes to kids where if you look
at things like the suicide rate you know
it's it's a hockey stick
and uh you know the data is always like
five years behind so last year the most
recent data I could find was from 2017.
this year it's from 2018.
um it was hockey sticking though up into
there and I don't see any reason why I
wouldn't keep hockey sticking
um and I think there's just a real thing
that I it is diff it's going to be
difficult for social platforms to say we
we deserve to continue to operate the
way we have given the level of our
markets it's an interesting tension
between
freedom of speech and family values
particularly in conservative locales
when you're dealing with young people
and their access to social media tools
that we're discovering are very damaging
and how that butts up against that deep
entrenched interest in unfettered free
speech and think about this for a second
uh you know some of those harms have
nothing to do with speech so like sleep
deprivation Sleep Quality
has nothing to do with free speech right
but truncating access to a social media
site
can easily be interpreted as you know an
infringement on Free Speech but imagine
instead you came out and said hey you
have to publish how many kids are online
at 10 11 midnight one two three A.M you
know we're not saying you have to cut
kids off and then parents have to just
have the right to make that decision or
like one of the things I often suggest
is you know we've known for 20 years
that if you make a site slower
people use a less so like my husband
always likes to joke we all have
willpower at noon right like 10 a.m
everyone has willpower but like by the
time you get to 10 p.m you know that's
when you start Doom scrolling you start
dissociating and self-soothing with like
your phone
imagine a world where a kid stays up
till 2am and the next day when they're
kind of hungover on Instagram and math
class you know a little thing pops up
and says when do you want to go to bed
tonight
I mean the kid says 11. my mom wants me
to go to bed 10. I want to go to bed at
11. and for two hours or three hours
before 11 the app gets a little bit
slower and a little bit slower and a
little bit slower
like around 11. but isn't every kid just
gonna say I'm gonna go to bed at 2AM I
don't I don't I don't think so because
like kids feel bad the next day yeah and
if you could have a software it is so
powerful but that's because we don't
have a soft Landing right now we pop up
a little thing saying it's 10 p.m do you
want to go to bed and and I don't know
about you I had dismissed right we don't
have soft Landings right now it's tough
you're asking kids to to bring a knife
to a gunfight you know with these
incredibly powerful tools that are that
are pitted against developing Minds you
know even even the most conscious and
well-intentioned Among Us are powerless
to fight it's Wiles you know and so the
fact that young people are contending
with this you know we're we're running
this massive experiment you know at the
greatest scale imaginable and it's very
unclear how this is going to pan out but
early indications are it ain't [__]
good it's not good
so the thing that was terrifying for me
about the Surgeon General advisory was
you know they said if your kid uses
social media for more than three hours a
day they're at uh like double or triple
the risk of getting depression or
anxiety the average kid in the United
States uses these products for three and
a half hours a day
right uh 30 of kids say they're on until
midnight or later most weeknights most
school nights like you're totally right
like we are
um when I went to the State of the Union
so I was a guest of the first lady at
the State of the Union I don't know a
year ago year and a half ago and
um he said we are running a national
experiment on our children
and I I had actually forgotten about
that line until like when my book came
out in one of the interviews I did they
played that sound bite
and I think if more people thought about
it that way and said you know we're
running a national experiment on our
kids like what say should the public
have in that experiment I think we'd
have very different conversations yeah
we should all have a say and that kind
of gets to The Core theme of the book
which is agency like the book is called
The Power of One
you might think that that that refers to
like you being this all-powerful
whistleblower but it's really a call to
action to all of us to get more engaged
with this and to get more involved and
to realize that we all have more agency
yeah we're not powerless than then we
believe that we have so talk a little
bit about you know how to get people
engaged and active around these issues
and and where they can plug that
um enthusiasm you know I think it's it's
interesting like um I had an interview
like two weeks ago with um a relatively
young woman she's like in her 20s and
and it kind of felt like we had I had
stumbled into a therapy session like I
spent like a solid 20 minutes of that
interview just trying to convince her
that there's hope right that that
they're thinking she's so done down
social media Rabbit Hole she's like how
is there any chance we're ever gonna
stop these giant corporations and and
one of the things I I pointed out to her
was you know I think the first the first
step is that we have to believe the
change could be possible
and the the thing I told her was like
you know one of the first quotes in the
book is from a guy named baklav Havel
who wrote The Power of the powerless
so for for those of you who are not cold
war studies minors
um I I'm old enough to remember yeah and
in the in the Soviet Union you know if
we had gone to anywhere in the Soviet
Union in 1960 and said will the Soviet
Union Fall no one would have said that
they'd be like there's this like iron
iron grip
and and he said you know there's this
this uh you know you can feel like
there's no potential to change because
the Soviet Union figured out a way to
glue things like to make them stuck you
know instead of being a totalitarian
state where they just ruled by force he
said there are post-totalitarian State
you know they they rule by ideology that
if you cross the ideology the ideology
just heals around you
so in a system where if you are a
powerful or you're powerless if you
speak out the system just heals around
you and you know shunts you to the side
you know what is left like what is your
power what is your agency what is your
power left
and he says you know you start by
valuing yourself and saying I am a human
being and I have dignity
you know I think if we started more
conversations on social media just from
that simple of a lens like saying you
know right now Facebook is not really
indicating they value our dignity you
know what what would what would social
media look like if it did it did look
like they valued our autonomy and our
choices you know for example
you mentioned Netflix when I was sick I
watched a lot of um really depressing
Netflix and I think I didn't even
realize that I had like gotten into the
darker depths of of the catalog like the
True Crime Dahmer oh no like like I
don't know Moody Scandinavian dramas you
know like you can be real dour on
Netflix if you want to cry yeah I like
it but when I started getting better you
know I'd open up Netflix and I'd be like
nothing appeals to me right it's like
like I try to search for comedies I try
to see Netflix only knew that I feel
better now yeah exactly
um so you're thinking like I should I
need to fix this algorithm well I didn't
even think about it until I moved in
with some new people during covid so I
went to Puerto Rico I'm moving some new
people they had their own Netflix
account and it was delightful like there
was all this wonderful stuff on Netflix
um but I haven't even realized that I
had gotten into a corner of the
algorithm right like like imagine a
world where and you of all people yeah
it's interesting so imagine you know
imagine we said hey step one I matter as
a human I have dignity I deserve to be
treated with respect you can imagine
things like you know maybe we should
have the right to reset algorithms you
know you shouldn't have to give up all
your watch history and all your like
ratings like like I've I have a watch
list of stuff I want to watch in the
future should I have to walk away from
my data in order to get the algorithm to
reset and this becomes like a really big
deal when it comes to kids because like
when I've talked to therapists about
kids with saying eating disorder or who
have been self-harming you know kids are
forced to choose between their pasts you
know all their friends all these moments
of their life they've documented and an
algorithm that threatens their future
that's really interesting it seems like
an easy fix you would be able to do that
because imagine the young person or
anybody who's contending with some kind
of mental health issue eating disorder
or otherwise they realize they need to
get well they engage in some kind of
recovery process they're getting better
but when they open up their apps they're
getting exposed to the same content that
fed that you know maladaptive Behavior
pattern that's not great yeah so so
they're faced with the choice it's that
whole thing of like it's on the user
yeah right and so what they have to
delete their account or unfriend
everybody in order to reset it it when
there could be some healthier tools a
happy medium yeah and I think that's
like the recurrent theme that I want
people to walk away from is that we have
been sold by the social media companies
that there are only these very Stark
absolutes like extremes
and there there could be like happy
mediums you know things where we say you
know let's design to put control back in
the user's hands or to make patterns
that were invisible visible and and I it
you know that's not enough like we need
companies to have to pay for social
costs too
but they're like really easy for steps
so the second thing is you know we we've
started from change is possible I matter
I deserve to be respected to you know
taking care of other people right like
coming in saying if you have and this is
part of what vocal of hoffel talked
about he said you know start just by
saying I refuse to let you humiliate me
I refuse to let you devalue me
second is I want to care for my friends
and family
right like I'm I'm gonna also remind
them they matter you know I I think
until we get social media that is safer
we have to start saying I'm gonna we
need to redefine some of the rituals of
what it means to care for each other you
know uh talk to your parents talk to
your your kids talk to your friends and
family about how they use social media
right how would you feel if you found
out your friend died because they were
getting sucked down a rabbit hole of
Despair and and you didn't know
right and I think it's just one of these
interesting things where like
I don't know maybe I'm like a radical
and I'm like what if we said hey I'll
show you my Instagram feed if you show
me yours right right like like maybe I'm
a radical something because I'm like
what if we just tried it you know like
what how it how would the world change
yeah you know and we're all operating on
some level on this low-grade assumption
that our feed looks like our friend's
feet exactly but we're all living in our
own silence unique like worlds as a
result of us my my husband is much
better at Twitter than I am like he much
more actively engages in it I think he
has more time than I do more patience
whatever
um I like swim in the ocean more than he
does he still have a bunch of troll
accounts oh he does uh he doesn't have
his money he actually has he has a check
he has a blue check mark now and he
actually uses his own name because he he
can't just you know draw all the time
because uh when when Elon came in he
lost like 20 or 30 troll accounts
um interesting uh because my my husband
used to have a hobby of he really likes
finding Chinese information operations
and then needling them
so he likes to make them like
interesting like ask them very
reasonable questions and watch whatever
hilarious answers they say back but he
he lost um he lost like 20 accounts when
Elon came through and did the first wave
of house cleaning I lost my blue check
and I have not subscribed and I found my
uh my use and engagement on that
platform to have gone from being my
favorite place to engage with people to
almost nothing hmm yeah
yeah
um I think the enough people left
there's a very different tone yeah it
just it feels very different to me
um but for what I was going to say was
like when I say this idea of like you
know what if we looked at each other's
feeds like I actually lived that like my
my husband because he engages with
Twitter more he mostly does it for like
National like his his account is much
more like National Security news
oriented like I literally like we lay in
bed and when he starts like Doom
scrollingly at night like I'll sit and
like you know enjoy his feed with him
and occasionally I annoy him because I'm
like I want to read that so you have to
slow down
um uh but we can do these things it's
not like they they have to be alien
actions yeah somebody suggested I'm not
taking credit for this and I'm sure
you've thought of it
um a great tool to add to Twitter or
other platforms would be when you visit
somebody's profile page you can hit a
button so then you see their feed yeah
like you're so you could live in that
person's experience and see what they're
seeing I think that would be they're
gonna be cool very cool people could opt
into it yeah and then you can go oh this
is what this person's reading all the
time and that's maybe why they're
posting in this way I understand this
person a little bit better than I did
prior yeah that'd be cool so in the
interim while we're wrestling with all
of these problems existential and
practical like what are what are some
best practices around how to interface
with these tools like we need to
understand just how powerful they are
how addictive they are the many pitfalls
and risks of engaging with them but they
are part of our lives and our identity
and and you know we're not gonna
nobody's gonna become a Luddite or you
know delete their account I mean some
people may delete their accounts but for
the most part these are things we have
to figure out some kind of healthy
symbiosis with and and I want to
acknowledge like you know when I talk
with this idea of like I would work at
Facebook because we can't leave people
behind right you know there's people who
for whom Facebook is the internet the
flip side of that is there's lots of
people in the United States who don't
have the luxury of getting to do a lot
of socializing in person
you know socializing in person costs
money you need to get there maybe you
have to buy food to be in the space
maybe there's other things we keep
devaluing um getting rid of the public
spaces where we could interact with each
other you know people don't join bowling
leagues anymore or garden clubs that
kind of thing
um and so there's a bunch of people whom
even in the United States we need to not
leave behind
um but the next thing I would say is um
I saw this app recently on on when I was
you know on my book tour a couple weeks
ago
um that I I loved which was it it just
um when you open any social media
account
it tells you how many times you've
opened it today and a little thing goes
across the screen very slowly that
counts down like five four three two one
and then asks you do you really want to
open Instagram like do you really want
to open YouTube and I I love that idea
of of just giving people a little bit of
friction a little friction
um because
um one thing that people do is they use
these as like digital pacifiers you know
you're feeling a little anxious you're
feeling a little uncomfortable instead
of sitting and just enjoying the silence
or like watching the the scenery go by
in your Uber or whatever you know I we
pull out our phones and we just we
immediately Dive In
any kind of moment of intentionality
gives you a chance to make more of a
real Choice what is that app called you
know I I put it in yeah
I haven't heard of that I've heard it
yeah other you know other sort of apps
that you can put on your phone that you
can set hours where certain apps don't
work etc
um I think it's important to reclaim our
boredom you know if we want to be able
to express ourselves creatively and do
our best thinking and be able to respond
to the world around us and be available
for the people we care about we have to
uh reprioritize the importance of
rumination and quietude and those
moments and I'm as guilty as anybody you
know like I'll fill every
opportunity you know standing in line or
or what have you to check the phone and
and you know lose myself a little bit
I'm like I'm powerless yeah you know
it's really hard I have a lot of
compassion for people that are suffering
and feel powerless to you know make any
kind of adaptive Behavior change around
these things I I think there's some
other low low hanging fruit it's like
charge phones not in the bedroom that's
a tough one you know kids charge their
phones in the parents bedroom yeah
adults should once the cat's out of the
bag as somebody with a bunch of kids
like it's hard to you put the genie back
in the bottle on that one well that's
why the kids phones can charge in your
room but like your phone could charge in
the kitchen or something you know you
can buy an alarm clock for 10 bucks it
will wake you up in the morning
um that's one of those ones that I'm
really
um uh
I need to do it right like my advice is
as I do them scroll late at night and
and my husband totally calls me out on
it and so I need to like start charging
the the phone in the kitchen probably
the the final thing I kind of want to
ask you about is is this conflict or
tension between
immediacy like we need Solutions like
we've got you know they're they're like
as you like as I open up this
conversation with this idea that if we
don't fix this tens of millions of
people are going to die your own words
yeah um there is a sense of urgency
around solving these problems yeah well
also simultaneously like appreciating
long-termism like we're in for the Long
Haul here yeah we gotta get through this
uncomfortable adolescent phase and and
learn how to do better
um both those things are true and
important yeah how do you how do you
kind of as an advocate now who's in the
public Spotlight talking about this
stuff all the time you know what is the
message that you want to
um put out there in terms of what we
need to do now to address the immediacy
I totally get like I think I frustrate
people because I don't come out and
demand more sooner right it's like I
know when I first came out
um a friend of mine who who is very
active in this space you know he was
like you need to pick like one thing
that you want them to do like maybe it's
like cut the reshare chains you need to
pick one thing and push to get that one
thing you're not going to get anything
more than them
um and uh and part of why I have
resisted that so hard is is like I think
the problem of social media is there
weren't enough people sitting at the
table
right like they're all these trade-offs
and all these externalities this social
costs and there weren't enough people
who actually got to have a say in the
process like it was made internally by
very smaller people who were working
under very constrained incentives
and
um you know we have to start with
transparency because I really believe
having a democratic conversation about
how to move forward is so essential and
so it's a little it's a little hard
because like I fully acknowledge the
house is on fire
and like coming in and saying we should
have smoke detectors like I totally get
that's not satisfying but right now
there are so few people in the world who
get to participate in a conversation
about how to move forward
I don't think it would I think you'd be
swapping out one dictator no Mark for
another dictator me if you're just like
Francis fix it for us right and so we
really need to immediately get
transparency
we we're we're going to keep working at
be on the screen on things around like
how do we onboard and and up level you
know uh concerned parents litigators
Regulators investors
because all of those actors together are
how safety happens right it's investors
saying we need to manage for long-term
risk it's litigrators that say we need
to create the right side of incentives
and so I think all in
um
you know we start with transparency and
then we begin the hard work of actually
figuring out where do we go from yeah
what is the floor are you doing your own
kind of like youth education red teaming
with social media projects where you get
kids in and you're like design your own
social okay what happens when that
person says that what do you do like how
would you fix that like creating
literacy in in like a generation of
young people who are obviously going to
be inheriting all of this yeah um at the
earliest you know phases of their
development seems to be I mean that's a
longer term solution to this but I
really like that idea of injecting that
awareness in as early as possible I
think there's two kinds of Education
that are really urgent so so one is
um is is that so did you did you do high
school journalism no no or like yeah so
there exists in the world high school
newspapers there even exists junior high
school newspapers
so hot take do you think there are any
good Junior High news newspapers in the
world I have no idea probably I think
almost certainly not but I mean like I'm
not I'm not I'm not trying to rain on
them like that's not why we do it like
it's we're not we're not funding those
you're exposing them to the principles
around journalism we're saying you know
journalism plays such an important role
in a democracy right so the first pass
at history you know it's uh digesting
information helping people get to have a
chance to have opinions
um that we believe we need to expose the
broadest number of people possible to
the process of Journalism
we are shifting over our information
environment from one where it's all
about a structured process with
journalistic traditions and ethics and
and protocols to one that's
decentralized or is run by algorithms
but we don't have a way of like actually
beginning to expose people to those
choices and so one of the things that we
want to do is is build a lab bench kind
of like um did you take chemistry in
high school it's like the chemistry lab
bench you used in high school is
remarkably similar to what you would use
in college or if you're a graduate
student or if you're a full-blown
chemist that lab bench facilitates a lot
of levels of of understanding you know
if we had a simulated social network we
could have you know High School data
science clubs where kids could argue
over you know should you have to click
on a link to reshare it and you could
play the ads team and I could play the
new user team and they could play the
non-english user team or the kids team
so you're you're you're you're you're
bringing the debate ecosystem into this
or the model un yeah you know or mock
trial you know like like how do we make
kids say hey actually these products I
use can be built in a very large number
of ways
you know there are choices being made
there's consequences of these choices
and to be real clear every single time
we change them it's not like it's either
good or it's bad it's it some some of
those stakeholder groups are going to
benefit some are not do we still ship um
so that's one kind of knowledge that I
really want like we're very actively
building towards and we love support if
anyone wants to give us support yeah so
what is the what is the website for that
oh um so our website is
beyondthescreen.org and please reach out
also my email is Francis at
francishaugen.com but um but the second
kind of knowledge I like to think of it
as like
um Community governance right or or like
addressing the idea that
we are actually very rapidly stripping
um Social Capital from our children so
I'll give you I'll give you an example
um I was told by
um uh a member of either like the
American Academy of Pediatrics or the
Academy of pediatric psychologists that
there now exists non-profits that teach
14 year olds how to play pickup
basketball
so take a step back for a second like
when you and I were kids there were not
startups that taught kids how to play
pickups no but there wasn't a need for
that so why wasn't there a need for it
right because we weren't at home staring
at screens we were out at the playground
and somebody's older brother taught us
how to do it and so I think what
happened was it used to be if you wanted
to play you just showed them and
sometimes there weren't enough kids and
so like you know the 14 year olds had to
let the 12 year old play they're like
he's smaller she's smaller not very good
but we need one more person
today those 14 year olds all coordinate
on their phones they show up at 4 pm on
Tuesday they always have enough people
and they never let the 12 year old play
and so now you have to figure out how to
do intentionality around propagating
that knowledge
we are facing I think a really serious
crisis amongst teenagers because for two
years we shut the schools down
right the the Juniors and seniors that
were supposed to socialize The Freshman
sophomores they didn't have those
moments
um and now the Juniors and seniors are
those old freshmen and sophomores right
like we're we're cutting they weren't
indoctrinated into that mentorship
mentality yeah yeah
um and and I really felt this in college
right like I was part of the first
graduating class at a college and so I
met we never had upperclassmen that
taught us how to be adults
right like we had to go and be seniors
for four years and I don't think it was
good for any of us
um so there's this interesting question
of like let's say we went into high
schools and we said hey we're going to
teach you about Network effects like the
idea of you guys are locked in right now
and we're gonna teach you about the
business model and we're gonna teach you
about the idea that like if you want to
decide to spend more time in person with
your friends they have to make that same
decision at the same time or you don't
get to
right
okay now you all know that that you're
not you know just leaves floating in the
river like you are people who can make
choices
let's fill an assembly and say hey
let's just start out how does this make
you feel like have the kids vote and
just put it up on the screen you know
how does it make you feel when you use
social media because it most of you say
it doesn't make you happy
how much time do you spend on social
media like let's check on our phones
together how much time do you spend okay
if you could set a rule for the whole
school on how much time you're going to
spend online
what would you choose
are you a three-hour Day School are you
four hour day school are you a one hour
day school because every hour you're on
there you're not with your friends
um what would happen like that's like an
area I really want to play out in where
like this question of can kids intervene
and start teaching each other social
skills can they start can we intervene
at the level of a community instead of a
single kid or a single family well that
speaks to agency and also this idea of
self-regulation because ultimately it's
it is as much as it's it shouldn't be on
the individual it is on the individual
and we have to make these choices
ourselves about how we're going to
engage with these things and you know
the younger you can get to somebody and
and give them that sense of agency where
listen you're a sentient human being and
I trust you and you're not gonna have to
figure out how to be responsible for
yourself like what do you want and
engaging with a young person at that
level about these things I think is is
really
um can be a powerful thing it should be
part of like yeah Elementary School
curriculum yeah
um you have a hopefulness in how you're
approaching this and I think that
hopefulness is rooted in an
understanding that change takes time and
so this is not you know hey I came out
and I testified and I went on 60 Minutes
and my work here is done this is perhaps
work that has no end but is worthy of
you know devoting your time attention
energy and and life too and when you
think of the whistleblowers over the
years you mentioned Auto Safety
obviously Ralph Nader he's sort of a
Talisman for you
um there aren't that many I mean there's
Edward Snowden in the NSA there's Daniel
Ellsberg and you know we all saw Russell
Crowe uh portray Jeffrey weigand in The
Insider uh and and there's you like
there's these sort of iconic figures
that don't pop up that often and create
kind of a bit of a lightning bolt moment
but the Groundswell of change in the
aftermath of that is something that we
need to appreciate does take time I
would say the transformative moment for
me that was kind of like the the moment
my life pivoted was
um I really like so I'm I'm a big nerd
uh when I travel I live Maritime museums
and railroad museums so I'll show you I
I'm odd um I really like museums about
cities like I like places that tell
their own stories and I really like
museums about individual people because
like you you get to like I really like
um I really like understanding people
like I really like connecting with them
and you know I've been to ones about
artists political figures Architects
like you know I just enjoy people and I
my one of my favorite single person
museums is the museum for Indira Gandhi
in Delhi
um so I was in Delhi for a wedding and
um uh it's a really cool Museum because
they tell her life story from like
letters and newspaper clippings that are
in context to that moment so it's all
contemporaneous documents and like
artifacts and they had this article
about her when she was five so she's the
only child of neru who's like one of the
founders of India and this article is
about her leading a March of children
through the streets of Delhi when she
was five so I think thousands of
children it's called the monkey Army and
one it shows you how different parenting
standards were a long time ago because
who would let their child go on a mass
of like thousands of five-year-olds
today but but two it was like a catalyst
for me because I think she was in her
40s when India became free right and I
had never like I had watched the Gandhi
movie or whatever and been like oh like
you know Gandhi needs salt in the ocean
and India became free or whatever but I
hadn't thought about the idea it took
them decades like it took them like 70
years to become free and if you had
asked anyone in the world in 1875 Well
India will the British ever leave India
no one in the world except for like you
know the hundred people gathered from
the Indian National Congress would have
said there's a chance
and I think today like I I have a line
in the book you know fatalism is a sign
that someone is trying to steal your
power
right like when we say there's no chance
we can do something like
um so much Innovation comes from like
some crazy person saying what if it was
different
and like I look at it as you know
we're going through a transformational
moment like the idea that our economy
could go from being transparent to
opaque
like we will wrestle with this for
decades
um and so it's it's easy for me to get
up every day because it it takes it
takes time any last
um thoughts like is there anything else
that you think people get wrong about
you
um you've done a million interviews
you've got this book out now interesting
um obviously you know a lot of people
are talking about the ideas that you're
talking about but they're also talking
about you yeah is there anything that
frustrates you around maybe some
narratives that get out there
um I've really liked this conversation
like one of the things that's nice about
podcasts is you get to have like such a
larger depth like you get to talk about
such a broader set of things
um a lot of the press coverage in the
United States has been you know in seven
minutes or 15 minute chunks and so we
asked the same questions over and over
again
um
I think the thing
probably the thing that's most
frustrating for me
um in terms of like narratives is uh and
we have always like we we've really like
my non-profit has really struggled to
fundraise because there's a perception
that people have given us lots and lots
of money and
um if people realized how little we had
been given and like I've had to pay like
out of pocket for even basic staff for
things I think they would be really
shocked right because there's this
perception that like well Piero meteor
is funding you yeah yeah uh the uh so
his his nonprofit illuminate
um is has never given me anything other
than like logistical support okay that
was one of those conspiracy theories
right that there was like the
billionaire yeah he well he's for people
that don't know he's one of the PayPal
guys yeah made a bunch of money and is a
big philanthropist now
um but his non-profit gave you aid but
it wasn't like he had any yeah personal
involvement paid me paid they paid on
for plane tickets to Europe and like
people to introduce me to like
politicians and stuff in Europe but like
it's one of these things where it's like
you know my salary is paid on public
speaking so like if you want to invite
me to a conference that's always lovely
because that currently is like the thing
that pays for my assistant and things
like that um and so I think that's
probably the thing that frustrates me
the most because like what people think
if you have a book out that you're a
millionaire yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um I'm sure there's anything else where
I haven't gotten acid oh you got that
sweet crypto cash right uh what's going
on I love that that Meme well I I would
say I've I I I'm I I was raised on
Vanguard you know like Vanguard mutual
funds you should have a diversified
portfolio and I I totally believe you
should have like five to ten percent in
crypto but that is not a life-changing
amount of crypto but you moved to Puerto
Rico you're part of like the whole CR
you know the bleeding edge of the crypto
movement yeah no I well I lived in San
Francisco during covet and it was really
cold and um really lonely right like I I
um I talk about in the book I had to
relearn to walk and I still have um very
bad pain in my legs neuropathy from the
because I I used to be I got bad enough
that I was paralyzed beneath my knees
and I can I can hike all day now I can
walk on my toes but like um every
whenever I'm cold and LA today is cold I
know you guys don't believe that but you
know 70 is cold
um in Puerto Rico I can leave my AC off
in my office and it just stays 85 and
like that costs a thousand dollars a
month in San Francisco right and so like
I I can't speak to any of the reasons
why my other friends moved there but
like I moved there because like a bunch
of people were like oh we're gonna go on
an adventure
um and now I'm there yeah you've been
there for a while too you like it down
there I I love it like um
um in in Puerto Rico you can live on the
beach like you can you can have a condo
on the beach where you open your windows
and you hear the water
and like my husband and I we go swimming
four to five days a week in the in the
ocean
and we we have this thing we call
descending uh descending body bodies of
water of descending size where we go in
the ocean
at some point we get a little cold and
we go to the pool at our condo and it's
like one or two degrees warmer and then
we have um an inflatable hot tub which
sounds like a ludicrous object but for
250 dollars we got a Coleman Hot Tub on
sale and it only goes up to like 104
which turns out it's not enough hot
enough yeah right
um but like I don't know like I I I
can't imagine living anywhere else like
we get to do that you know four days a
week good for you and we could never
afford to do that in like Los Angeles
yeah so
um
that's great yeah
I appreciate it welcomes you yeah I've
been there I love I like it there yeah
it's super nice I I get the appeal yeah
get the appeal
um it was great to talk to you thank you
I think that you're courageous and the
example that you're setting is is
inspirational and I think the work that
you're doing is vitally important so I
appreciate you coming here to share
um the book The Power of one is out
everywhere if you find we'll link it up
in the show notes and all of that
um and uh I'm at yourself my pleasure
thank you for you yeah thank you really
it's it's it's amazing what you're doing
and uh I'm here to support you so
appreciate it so much thank you